what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the
pregame before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started so a couple announcements before
we start the show the first guys is that
we have two clips channels just pearly
clips and pearl daily oh we just
launched the new clips channel right
it's like
Pearl pearly things TV so make sure you
go subscribe to all three of those also
guys um make sure you subscribe to
Christine's channel that link is in the
description and also the new audacity
Network page we're going to be launching
new talents with the network so if you
want to see some of your favorite panel
guests and show regulars come back and
make some new content make sure you
subscribe to that as well also guys we
have four membership tiers the first
tier lets you be a part of the chat
tonight and over how many how many likes
to open up the chat king um 1,500 okay
1,500 likes and we will open up the chat
to everybody and King how many dollars
over super chats are we reading 20 okay
so if you guys have a question or a
comment for the panel you can donate $20
and I will read it please guys be nice I
will read them but it's very awkward for
me if you you say mean things all right
so please please be nice tonight um yeah
and I think that's pretty much it uh
make sure you subscribe and follow my
Instagram just pearly things one um okay
guys to start we are going to do name
age relationship status and a fun fact
about yourself starting here go around
and then second
row my name's Wana I'm 29 and a fun fact
is I think I just put in the spot I
don't know you you have any
hobbies
um not right now I don't know no hobby
okay all right hi I'm I'm Beth Quinn um
I'm 26 I'm single and a fun fact about
me is that I'm a stripper turned corn
star wow amazing go ahead hi I'm Bonnie
I'm 28 um I'd say I'm just a big nerd
really like space gamer nerd that's
about it really you stream or something
I do stream on Twitch yeah not like
often when I can when I can but like a
game nonstop
yeah hi I'm s I'm 28 and I'm in a
relationship and I don't really know
what a fun fact is about me I don't
really know you're TV presenter yeah
yeah I've said that so many times they
that yeah and and we're going to do a
therapy episode so you're coming with me
to therapy right watch out for that
that's going to be a good one all right
go ahead oh me yeah hi my name is dizzy
Goku um I'm 27 single and I'm a musician
so I singer
songwriter that's it and I got a brand
new song called big brown eyes so if you
want to listen to that it's on
Spotify hi I am prolific official singer
songwriter also businesswoman I am
single you hold the mic close to your
mind can you hear me yeah prolific
official singer songwriter businesswoman
and I am single and I'm
42 hi my name is Telicia mafin I a legal
consultant so I specialize in criminal
defense I represent a lot of the known
London rappers um up against serious
crimes such as murder manslaughter Etc
and I am also single and successful
businesswoman that's very that's that's
an interesting fact do you have you ever
have you ever defended someone that you
know is guilty I mean I never know that
they're guilty so I take their
instructions as it comes and I represent
them don't they have to tell don't they
like have to be honest honest with isn't
there some like law where you can be
honest with your lawyer and they can't
tell anyone they're honest with me and
they give me their instructions and I
would follow them and carry them out
okay prove them as best as I can I had a
cousin who is a defense lawyer and he
said he preferred clients that were
guilty yeah because he said if he lost
he's like well they were guilty anyway
and if he
won he like if he won he's like well I
did my job yeah I mean I like I like a
challenge and I like to argue for what's
right so especially stick up for you
know people that are arrested and things
accused for things that they haven't
done MH um I mean I got to say I'm a
little taken back by this podcast
because I wasn't given the name or the
topic in advance I was told it was
something completely different okay but
I'm going to stick it out anyway so do
you like reject people that you know are
guilty well like if once you find out if
you know that they're guilty do you kind
of like reject them absolutely not I
would advise them as the best possible
way to take their case forward just
because somebody's guilty does not mean
that they should face a significant
sentence we would have to look at
mitigation and reasons behind it um and
that's the sort of things that the media
doesn't cover so I cover a lot of cases
that you see in the media today and like
I say a lot of the known rappers but you
only see what the media produces whereas
I go behind get the detail get the
mitigation get the instructions and we
deal with it from there what's the
biggest mistake that people make when it
comes to like if they if they commit or
if they're like accused of something is
like talking too
soon I mean I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't
say talking too soon so we go to the I
would go to the police station and be
there to take instructions and I would
advise based on that they would have to
wait I would advise to see what the
evidence says before they um disclose
too much okay
Christine hey I'm Christine Grace I am
23 years old in a relationship fun fact
about me I'm actually a YouTuber here at
the audacity Network so I work here with
pear and all the guys yeah yeah make
sure you subscri tell them to subscribe
oh yeah subscribe to my
channel Christine Grace Smith that's it
go go find it you got to plug yeah I'm
learning guys by with it's like I teach
her what is she go um I'm BK um 32 um
and from fact about me um Council
culture co-host best Council culture um
podcast in Birmingham going right now so
yeah is Birmingham I just found out
today someone told me Birmingham is like
the Vegas of the
UK I don't know who is I
live calm down come on let's not lie is
it no I didn't say it was like why are
you laughing is it not as good no you
need to go I will take you is okay wait
is it is it like worse than Vegas or
better no there's nothing Vegas about it
nothing so what come on guys come on
guys wait a minute you're from
Birmingham I'm from Leo that's like next
door I'm your she from Le the other City
okay anyway yeah Birmingham it's all
right it's I won't say it's anywhere
near um Vegas but it has its high is it
is is it more wild than London or less
wild less l oh it's not as crazy so why
did I actually yeah yeah you ever told
you that I think I think it was never I
don't know you can actually drive him
Birmingham yeah that's one thing it
doesn't take you 20 years to get around
5 minutes of Road gocha one gotcha yeah
and you guys did some Street interviews
today for the network so guys make sure
you subscribe to the audacity Network to
see their street interviews it was
pretty good um yeah we may be canceled
but ccel culture that's your that's your
podcast that's what we do that's what we
do okay what what about you um yeah I'm
the other half of the council coach
podcast Lee uh 30 years old and single
um fun fact
we done some content today for p so
check that out subscribe and do all this
stuff you
know okay so today's topic is why do
women love being
[__] yes yes okay now I just I just
have a question so I made a PowerPoint
okay I made a PowerPoint today and this
is just something I've noticed after a
year of doing shows okay so I made can
we pull up this PowerPoint look at me I
wanted to be a whiteboard but we didn't
have as much um Bas today all right so I
made a PowerPoint called what what men
want and to me I didn't really think
this was super complicated I just
thought this was kind of basic right I'm
not I'm I'm a very I like simple things
so let's go to the can you play it like
you can do preview like play the
slideshow no okay well we'll we'll try
for next time I
guess it looks good so far okay so you
go to the next one one not
fat no I didn't think this was crazy
right but I've had so much push back
when I say men don't like fat chicks
everybody's like ah Pearl you're such a
mean person and so evil and I thought to
myself I mean I thought this was
basic I think a lot of um only fund
girls five BBW do you think do you think
by do you think by and large the richest
most successful men with the most
options in Choice tend to
pick yeah your girls do more like do
well but I would say so but so do BBW so
do some guy some guys only like I I want
to do a caveat I want to do okay so now
this is no personal offense yeah you me
but I need pre I need pref I think
there's a difference between like porn
only fans and like what guys want for
wives M yeah right so so I don't think
it's like a fair comparison so when men
say I want a wife in general in general
they're like I don't want a fat chick I
don't know oh no oh no I know some guys
yet that only go for curvy bigger women
like I know especially one guy I know he
all of his exes have all been like size
20 or married now he is married to a
very curvy woman and very and what
what's his is he hot rich and Tall he's
not hot and Rich
there we go so we're talking about the
hot rich men I okay I'll give you an
example I think we can see what men
truly want when we look at the men with
the most choice so if an ugly chick
right if we and we can do this with
women too if we look at the women with
the most Choice the most beautiful women
they tend to pick Rich tall successful
handsome men right right so I think when
we look at men and we look at the men
with the most choice we can say what do
those guys tend to pick you you know and
I I would argue the women that look more
like supermodels than lizo but they they
don't tend to they don't tend to laugh
either wait wait I wanna we'll get to
slide two but I want to have this
conversation first king yeah thank you
okay are we looking at a western
perspective it depends culturally I
would say all over yes I would say um I
I think this is a very like diverse
Studio here like we have people from
that were born in the Middle East to
Africa to England to Eastern Europe all
in this studio and I'd say if I pulled
them and where they're from typically
they like not fat now some guys might
like skinny with a butt but but we have
the small weight like you need the the
the
skinny like predominantly then because I
mean the other day I was watching a
documentary and there there's a village
I can't remember where it is but
literally the bigger they are the bigger
these women are they're seen as the most
beautiful and this lady couldn't get up
off of her seat okay so we can all think
of an exception of a really hot chick
that married or dated a fat broke loser
right we can all think of an exception
but that doesn't make the rule the rule
right so why why as women are we always
bringing up this Tri I've heard this he
he put his hand on his head because I've
heard so much about this tribe that I
want to oh every every time I have this
topic it's like the tribe that I want
I'm determined I'm going to go to this
tribe cuz I want
I like I'm starting I'm like what the
hell so but I would say in general no no
men don't want fat chicks do you think
it's like genetics like people just like
people that are fit and attractive and
can yes you know yes I think people tend
to like healthy yeah healthy people
women like strong men we like yeah
exactly they like skinny women I mean
women have more fertility issues the
fatter they are can I can I ask you
something yes I mean these are opinions
that you have on men like fatter women
and stuff I mean I mean I said I said
that men don't like men don't like fat
women that's it I mean I mean different
so I'm all for if you want to be big
boned or if you want to be slim whatever
is best for you you know I don't judge
anybody by what they are or how they are
but where do you get this information
from do you research and see do you
speak to a number of mouths because I
think in this modern day and age a lot
of women are curving when you actually
have a look at statistics and you have a
look at what the you K say is actually
obese it's like a 10 to 12 I mean in
America as well there are a lot of
bigger women and they I've seen a lot of
you
know
married bigger women um you know doing
music and stuff I've often traveled and
it's like it's the norm to be bigger
there so I mean in Europe it's you know
so so I'll tell you I would say my
number one source is real life when I
say any any room I say men men in this
room right here raise your hand if you
would prefer a fat chick raise your hand
anybody what's anybody yeah but that's
not fair you can you say what is fat
what size is fat um I would say when you
have an unhealthy BMI I would say that's
the Baseline as a BMI I was going to say
a difference there's a difference
between what's being there's a
difference between being fat and being
curvy though now but like what is the
difference no no no but I feel like
you you you seen it in a like how how
you're explaining it is if like you are
fat like obviously there's women who are
slim big bonded I will call that curvy
you know I mean slim but um big back
sorry I will call that curvy you know I
mean your weight isn't down here what
would you what would fluffy be what
would fluffy be size would fluffy be
Mitch and um man Mitch and man I do you
know what I think that maybe back in the
day there were you know men preferred
Slimmer women but I also think that some
of it was because maybe they would be
embarrassed to say you know who they
really like and sort of thing but I
think today I see a lot of men saying
that they prefer you know they like
their preferences I I feel like it's
just the fact that men just ain't as
honest with women no more cuz women
sometimes hon when you see in the
comments and they're discussing you know
what they like there's just as much men
that say they like bigger women than as
there are that say that they like small
most of them don't most of them don't a
choice though that's what they have
access to I mean I don't know cuz I
don't know I don't know all of these men
I'm just saying that you know unless
I've gone out but this is why this is
this is why I go back this is why I go
back to what are the men with the most
choice pick I think it's each to their
own that's such small percentage of men
compared to the I I want to simplify
this do you guys think that men tend to
like fat women I think some men do I
think it's each to their own and I think
unless spoken TR again try again try
again try again try again large by and
large by and large do menend in my
opinion most of them there is a there is
a section of them that prefer bigger but
I'd say the most if you're going to say
percentage majority prefer smaller I
don't know I don't interact with that
many men to be able to give a good
enough you know point of view so I mean
I guess you would have from from my work
I see the girls that do the most
successful on um Instagram that have the
most followers are normally like really
slim girls like way Slimmer than me like
really skinny
they with bigger bums as well like
talking about you know the a bit bigger
you know they do like big bums they
do they like women that are women you
know like not not stick fin or stick fin
do well I think really well I mean can I
just add I think it's the way you've
said it you said fat women I think you
are they fat but it's the it's the tone
it's the it's the harshness but what
about the information the information I
guess if you ask someone with a lot of
choice okay they wouldn't go for someone
bigger okay but it doesn't necessarily
mean that they're ugly but why why can't
we use words to describe things why do
we always have to soften it like why do
weally every everyone on the everyone in
here has not said f like I'm I'm not
problem tell the TR this the problem you
know I think you're just more direct no
no I just I like to I just here's my
problem so I feel like whenever women
don't like words they like change them
so instead of fat we say plus size
bigger chubby you know and I'm just like
well let's just excuse that just kind
of it's just respecting people's
feelings you know you know what's funny
I didn't even call anyone fat I said men
don't like fat women I didn't call
anyone F you the difference is though
said maybe lizo but come on
the same thing no hold on no but if I
need to be honest with my fellow man I'm
going to tell him he fat that's the
problem now like you said it I believe
all women you know in B and I believe
everyone should be how they are but you
your solicit your job is to be honest
with people my job is to be honest not
judge I me it's Jud thing that I do is
that I don't judge or sit here and have
the right to say that anybody is fat so
it's not about saying that they're would
you not actually I have a question does
a doctor can a doctor tell a patient
that they're fat a doctor will say that
statistically they'll say that this
class is obese but if a woman is happy
with in that skin okay so if a doctor
has a right to tell the patient that
isn't it kind to help your friends by
giving them information that's true a
matter of opinion your if your friend is
Happy can I just say something if your
friend is Happy the shape and the way
they are and that may be your fat but
not my fat but if your friend is happy
in the way and the shape they are then
who are you to go and tell that friend
that they are fat I want to have
longevity with that
friend hold on if I'm being a real
friend I'm I'm supposed to be a friend
so what I lie to my friends now I tell
them some facts sometimes that's true
she Happ in her own skin who are you she
knows it's something
different let me give you an example a
chice of words you can describe
something in many different words but if
your friend's taking drugs say your
friend is taking crack and doing CRA are
you going to let them continue to take
crack cuz they're happy doing it that's
that's not the point I'm speaking about
descriptive it's about being descriptive
we're talking about things that are
unhealthy for you but it doesn't matter
what it is it's it's a choice of words
so what you're saying is okay please
friend problem with the fact you have a
problem with the words I could say to
them don't be a cracked I could say to
them don't take Nars say don't I'm
precisely I'm not saying that you can't
like okay can can we agree can we agree
300b that's
fair more there are ways to describe it
you know to soften figure it out the
blow you've got overweight you've got
you know your obese you've got your fat
you know yeah it just like obes how you
how you describe it it's just not it
doesn't I think regardless of us all
sitting here saying you're fat question
21 Stone we can agree fat right 21 Stone
are stone is please please be honest I
mean what what about you 21 21 stone is
that fat I mean how big is 21 Stone girl
how big are you right now okay that's
probably I mean I think that's it
depends on what fat is I think you're
going from fat to obese to sort of
bedridden I there's a big difference I'm
asking you because I just think you're
trying to argue here like I just think
I'm just stting I'm
okay well is it a fact that 21 Stones is
fat dear God
please are you are you judgmental are
you judal but you just made the Judgment
that they're probably fat probably
overweight 21 Stone but that would be
expect them to be in there I would not
be judgmental enough to go and tell them
you are fat you need to do this I would
say
judgment I would say honest but you're
sitting here I would say that's
dishonest but you're it's you're sitting
here saying fat women do this men don't
want fat women you've got no substance
to what you're asking I'll tell you I'll
tell you what I said I said men want
women that are not fat but where do you
get that from men I know a lot of men
that want curvy women that's not the
same thing if you look I feel like
that's an internal decision you don't
have to like voice it out what is like
it's an internal thing that you make
like you made your peace with it it's
like you made that decision okay I don't
want someone who's fat or I want someone
who's fat but then you don't have to
like verbalize it why can't we verbalize
things that are true if it's unnecessary
why is it unne isn't it helpful to women
to know what men want okay let me
clarify it so if I had if I had what if
I had someone who's fat right and um I
could just make that decision and say
okay like I'm not going to approach I'm
not going to approach her I'm not going
to talk to her right right because I'm
not interested cuz I understand that for
example by your words that I don't want
like someone who's F all right cool can
I all right so so this I don't have to
voice I don't have to walk up to her and
say listen want to approach you but
nobody but nobody did that all I said
all I said I said I had one statement
had one statement I said men don't I
said men want women that are not fat
that was it that was I gave you a bad
example your example I'll use that
example yeah so say say there's this
girl the one that you're not going to
approach yeah and and there's a lot of
other people not approaching you in fact
people rarely approach her and she
doesn't know why wouldn't it be easy if
if someone actually said to her and
didn't beat around the bush that's is
probably the reason why wouldn't that be
better for her yeah but that's not my
responsibility okay right I'll give I'll
give you an example we had a nice young
lady unnecessary we had a nice young
lady that came on her show she used to
be over 300 lbs and she was a very nice
young lady and she lost over and someone
told her she was fat she lost over a 100
PBS and now she has a boyfriend and I I
just personally believe that I think
that information was helpful you don't
think that would be helpful no it would
be it would be but it might crush
someone's spirit to complet like it
might it's it's like you're driving them
like to a corner and you're saying
listen I told you the truth so now you
can either change or you could just stay
the same you know what else crushes your
spirit you know what else crushes your
spirit uh a heart
attack okay fair enough fair enough you
got which is you know I mean and that's
like why I think I think especially like
we need people to be honest and it
doesn't help us to the thing is I come
from like a history of like my family
has diabetes so I kind of like try to be
careful with my weight you know so these
are things that I con like constantly
and actively like think about in terms
of like that because understand you went
to the extreme no like like no one's
going to I feel like we were talking
about the extreme n no but nice people
are not just going to walk over to
random we didn't even Define the
parametric like what what def F where SC
I did I I did Define it I did Define it
I said a healthy BMI that's what I said
I said men want women that are not fat I
didn't I didn't call anyone in here fat
I didn't call any okay lizo I might have
but it's like that's pretty fat that's
pretty you know I actually get called
fat all the time on Tik Tok like I get
called fat on live a lot and I get
called it on my comments on Tik Tok a
lot like all the time I get told I'm
overweight it's because they just fat is
their main word though fat it's always
you're fat you're too fat why are you in
a bikini you're too fat and I do think
that's where the word fat almost becomes
like people don't want to say it because
they know it gets thrown around in ways
that it shouldn't be thrown around
almost not even just the people that
you'd say have an unhealthy BMI cuz my
BMI is not unhealthy but I get thrown a
lot of fat hate well yeah they're trolls
I can see but I think that's where it
comes from where people don't like to
use that word it's like where do you
draw the line I I think um I just I I
don't even I'm not even a big I really
just think we should be able to say that
men like not fat women
okay like think about this we had this
was 24 minutes over one
[Laughter]
sentence I was just I mean I feel like
if we just said men like healthy women
you would have just moved
on what a healthy woman is a healthy
woman fat and then we and then that's
when we start defining it you know
that's what we start saying no I yeah
yeah exactly but I did Define I said
heal am I let's let me test the energy
of the room then the women the W the
women like what are you going to say I'm
going to test do women like broke men
oh
women I don't think it's about how much
money he's got in general you think
women like broke I can't tell you what
other women like but for me personally I
no it's the truth because I've been with
someone before that you know they might
not necessarily be in the greatest
position in life did you like I've been
I've been yes I did so why didn't you
still with him because we we the
no it's not that's a very immature point
of view why is it immature because it is
because that's very shallow it's not
shallow I have a question I have a
question I have a question have a
question okay two men two men exactly
the same they're exactly the same
personality everything one makes a 100K
thank you for being honest one makes one
makes 100K and at a bank and one works
at Tesco who are you picking rich bigm I
think
they're exactly the same no they're both
men exactly the same one's Rich one's
poor then if they're exactly the same
then I'm I am going to go for the one
that I can build with more and that is
more ambitious but that's that's not you
know in life you're never real going to
meet two people exactly the same no my
point is my point is it's like I don't
know why we just can't be
honest an unrealistic
scenario is
attractive this isn't a bad thing if I'm
not I'm not saying that but you're
saying you're sitting there you're
saying why can't people be honest I'm
telling you yes I am being honest it's
not just about but you're arguing with
me about the question and I'm not saying
it's only money there's other things
women select for it's not the only thing
but I'm saying I'm saying it's a factor
right it is a
factor an unrealistic scenario
no you you know you know what's actually
realistic the fact that whenever we say
something about a general thing like we
say generally the first thing you ladies
do is bring it back to yourself like I
would no but the reality go by your own
experience but that's not true because
question was would you no that's not
that was no I didn't I didn't I didn't
say would you I said do women the
reality is I didn't the reality is as
adults we can look at the world around
us and make inferences so whenever we
make a general statement we're not
saying this is the way it is for every
single person it is just if you look out
there what do you see normally what do
you see women normally select for even
in your entertainment industry what do
you see women select for in in your
business what do you it's connection
isn't it but with who who do they who
they usually look for to make the
connection
with want to hear what to say then let
me women women are starting to not uh
like the more or they are like basically
what what am I trying to say no
basically um women are starting to look
for like no connection basically like
they just want money basically I've I've
connected with broke
people people and I find people i' I've
been in love with a broke person before
and I've been in love with someone
that's not broke before to be completely
honest the only two people I've ever
loved and the broke person had no
ambition they didn't care about anything
and that was a complete turn off
want to deal with being broke is no
ambition and that's not attractive
correct and I didn't say it was the only
thing women select for other things too
yeah and it depends on the woman which
one she values but to act like it's no
Factor you're not going
to you're
not ambition
B to be BR you're not to be broke you're
not ambiti ambition is a characteristic
that equates to money it's a
characteristic that if through is likely
going to make you rich and I also feel
like in the current person is in their
life I also feel like in the
current going to as a result in the
sense you might meet someone for example
yeah um that person might have gone
through I don't know maybe a loss yeah
and they had everything and then they've
gone through this really bad time and
they're not focusing they're not
concentrating and they've you know
they're not as ambitious at that time
and I've I've seen
itar but then you know they've come out
the other side and they're back on their
game so they would have money again so
so then they are ambitious it doesn't
mean like but but the point is you're
not going to be with a broke guy forever
I'm not
saying exactly so so it's like what do
we if I said if I I I know nothing break
men okay I want to do a PowerPoint with
what women want and I'll see if the men
argue like we're not going to argue we
know what they want okay so let's let's
go to the next let's go to the next one
okay let's let's all right so the next
thing that um men typically want let's
let's show next one not a single mom oh
my God this one comes up all the time so
okay okay let's let's I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna so single mothers single
mothers and this is from Dr David
Baker's research this is a man that has
researched the history of sex and
produced multiple books on the topics
right
um and I I it's roughly about only 15ish
per of single moms will ever get a guy
to remarry them no the grass is not
greener on the other side most of the
time except for 15% of women if you're
Sierra you might be turn out okay but
probably not now now 20 22% of single
mothers will get a man to live with them
again yes so you might get a guy to live
with you but most single moms know there
is no happy ending no light at the end
of the tunnel I'm sorry don't shoot the
messenger I feel like have you ever been
to like a counselor St that happens all
the time single Ms get what all of it
well I'm telling you this is people do I
have heard guys say oh she's got a baby
I don't want to but I think they're just
scared of commitment that's the thing
guys so men in general don't want to
raise other men's kids can you say
single dad I would what can you apply it
in like reverse no I would say it's not
the
same I have a friend going through
something like that I would I and it
complicated relationship one person at
the time so I would I would argue that
no it's not the same um and there's
biological reasons for this typically if
a man has children it signals to women
that other women have selected him so
historically the concubines weren't
really too concerned with the king's
wife they just were concubines right but
yeah yeah yeah they never I get rid of
him way but this is evolutionary biology
we have to acknowledge that we we can we
can acknowledge the fact that human
beings we we are animals and we have
progressed in such a way that we can
observe General patterns about our
species and this is a general pattern
generally men male animals don't want to
have a woman that's got other children
and it's the same way that men generally
don't want a woman who's more
promiscuous because you can't guarantee
whose child it is when it comes out
women on the other hand I've heard a fun
fact it's like they say you tell me if
this is true for example they say white
males with blue eyes tend to go for
other like females with blue eyes
because they feel insecure they want to
like clarify that it's their child oh no
I ain't got blue
eyes that is true I feel like white
males do always go for like girls who
look similar to them I think in general
people might do that anyway so there's
like a whole study about people like
their eye color and how that affects
their choice of relationships as well
wow some couples look like brother and
sister I won't lie like sometimes I meet
couples and I'm like you look
related so do we have any disagreements
do men prefer do men prefer men prefer
women with no kids right right I prefer
men with no kids too I'm jealous will
kill there are some women there are some
women that that do have that right but
but I'm saying it's not it's not the
same across the board it usually doesn't
hinder a man's dating prospects like it
does a woman it's not the same I'm not
there are some women that will
disqualify men for it but I would argue
not the same yes okay so next one next
one so cuz I wanted I wanted to
ask all right so the next you want to
ask me what shallow white shallow I want
to know white shallow go go yeah go back
go ahead go ahead what's shallow I think
when you were saying that men don't want
generally don't want women with kids you
said it was shadow why it's like tunnel
vision you see we're in 2023 so a lot of
things has developed I think it's very
rare now day for you to find anybody
over over 20 whether male or female that
doesn't have children um and I think 70%
of women under 30 don't have kids where
do you get this statistic from because
this one this one again was from the the
evolution of sex Dr David Baker I'm
pretty sure the office of national
statistics were the one that have just
predicted that by uh 20 it's either 2030
or 20 2030 50.1% of women in England
won't have kids so that means more women
won't have kids than do have kids in
general the numbers are going down
believe it that for that age group I
believe I think it's more than ever that
young people don't want kids I have so
many friends that don't want kids my
crazy it's crazy it's a lot it's a lot
but I'm just still confused by why
shallow that they wouldn't want that
there's a lot of reasons why I mean like
I saying the job that I do I'm quite
indifferent so I would never favor one
and not favor the other but what I will
say is that I have two children of my
own um and that I am a successful
businesswoman who is not looking for a
man but rather focusing and building my
own thing and I think this conversation
is about a man what a man wants whatever
a man wants you I mean I think for me
and I think a lot of women out there
it's pretty irrelevant well if you don't
care what men want then why do you keep
arguing with
it say what I think is right I think a
lot of things of what I'll say is I what
I don't like is when has got tunnel
vision and when you've got your opinion
and you focus on that but when you're
neglecting to notice what's actually
around it's not but I think we need to
talk about General truths in the world
right there's it's not my truth it's the
truth I do but you're talking about a
specific age group as well
no I'm talking about men of all ages
there's patterns and Trends and men
don't tend to like single mothers now
some single mothers are hot enough to
get away with it only about 15% though
with
kidss would never say no yeah I I I
actually know like I have friends and
stuff that they would say that they want
to date they'd rather date a woman that
has had children so that they can
understand you know that whether they've
got kids I think if they've got
kids they're happier if they've got kids
if a guy's got kids I think they're
happier to get a woman that's got kids
but the guys not have kids I think they
get scared of it and then that's when
they don't no I would say say even men
with kids if they can don't want a woman
with I would say the preference I think
the preference for men is always know
kids with rare exceptions I have no
knowledge of that so it must be hard
enough raising your own kids without
raising other people's kids maybe
exactly I don't know I don't have kids
like this is probably nothing to do with
me but because that's what I guess it's
because the guy can't raise the kid
really how he wants to raise the child
that's the main problem because
obviously people that have children
you're not going to let him discipline
your child you're going have an issue
with that so obviously to a man it's a
problem because you can't discipline how
he wants to discipline the even if we
look at the science of it it's always
going to be difficult to raise a child
that isn't biologically yours I mean I'm
adopted and I I know a fair amount about
adoption statistics and adopted kids are
the hardest kids to raise because of
that dynamic because even when you're
adopted very young I mean I was adopted
at 9 months old even babies younger than
me taken from birth the biology isn't
there it's the same reason if you have a
surrogate mother um that baby has only
known the woman it's been inside even
though biologically it's the same as the
other mother it's only been inside this
one woman so then when you change that
up it it does change the dynamic and it
makes it difficult so I think you know
we can sit here all day and argue about
whether it's right whether it's shallow
or not but there is a biological fact
that raising a child that isn't
biologically similar to you is is going
to be more difficult than raising one
that ish I could imagine it's difficult
can imagine yeah thank you Christine so
the next one the next one now let's see
I want to see how how far we can take
this so the next thing that men want are
hear me out no abortions if men can pick
between a woman if men can pick if men
can pick between a woman that has killed
her child and not killed her
child wait wait wait wait I'll give you
wait let me let me finish they may not
find out but if they do find out they
would prefer no abortions to having
abortions that's absolutely wait I want
and I want to clarify talking
relationship marriage I was going to
clarify remember as I said earlier this
is for a wife and a mother not a chick
that's fun for a couple of months wait
does that would that matter to you if
you were going to marry her now did that
again sorry would that matter to you if
you were going to marry her and she had
an abortion if I was going to marry her
I mean with an ex partner with if
there's a I think the question is if if
you had a choice between a woman who has
and a woman that hasn't it really bother
you no what I'm saying if you had a
choice had the choice obviously if you
don't know you don't know but if you
know it does change your perspective
anything you know if I if I don't know
you've slept with 10 people but then I
find out you slept with 10 people it
don't matter how long I'm with you so
you're talking about if you if she'd
slept with a lot of people and
accidentally got pregnant you would
prefer a woman that slept with no people
and and didn't get pregnant is that what
you trying to say run that question by
me one more time so you would you would
prefer that a woman slept with no with
nobody and never got pregnant or someone
that slept with 10 people and got
pregnant how can she get pregnant and
then had an no and then had an abortion
she virgin or she's saying got pregnant
because that that would have to be that
would have to be your choice because be
girls get accidentally pregnant all of
the time
yeah Define accidentally Define
accidentally what do you mean accident I
mean you can be on contraception and
accidentally get pregnant of course yeah
but I mean that's not that's not like
but you need to you need to be specific
in accident because there's a difference
between missing the pill one day and
getting pregnant that's not an accident
okay that is a fault that you've made so
there's a big difference between actual
accient leads into the
mentality I think depend on how many
isn't the pill like
99.7% though isn't there still that one
chance the pill is about why why do you
go to the person no come on come
on there is some poor woman that
accidentally got pregnant okay what are
we talking about what are we put it into
perspective like I think it really
depends on how many abortions they've
had and what was the reasoning behind
why they've had the abortion cuz I'm not
going to lie if I if I was a male and I
know some females that like you know
like sometimes you get men right and
they're like oh um I don't want to be
with this woman because she's got kids
or she's got kids for how many people or
whatever it is and then they might go
for a female that maybe has one child or
has no children but little do they know
that woman yeah I'm going to try not to
swear all right so that woman goes home
with somebody every weekend when she
goes out she's probably had flipping 10
abortions as she's come out of Mary
stopes or whatever she's D her breeden's
driving her down the road and she's
holling at man at the window as she's
just come out Mary stopes do you know I
know some disgusting people you know
what I mean so it really depends on what
you're talking about we're talking about
preference like if we know if we
know you if I if I had to if I had to if
I had to talk to my brothers and I said
Adam Austin they're really great guys
and they really they really are they're
awesome and really they're amazing
they're really good people they they're
Engineers they're very successful at a
young age they're really I I would argue
husband material for most women right
yeah I mean I come from good cloth you
know and um they're very smart and
helpful kind everything really I would
argue most women wanting a guy and I
said okay what would I recommend I would
say if you ever hear a woman's head in
abortion you got to leave her ass you
got to leave her yeah I'll tell you
because I'll tell you why I'll tell you
why wait wait wait because if she's
going to kill her kid what's she G to do
to you oh my godar me out hear me out
hear me out hear me out your kid is like
you're supposed to love it more than
anything it's not a child never but I
disagree I arue I would AR I would arue
who said it's a clump of cells who said
that who just said it's a clump of
cells no clump of Cs a clump of Cs have
you seen an abortion take place depends
on how far along it is you know they
have a heart they have a
heart guys guys guys okay Christine who
who said the clump
who said it okay go ahead Christine
didn't talk to her what is it a baby
have you seen a fetus can we get up a
picture of a six they have a heart from
five weeks old yeah I think you can we
could show it they do the thing is you
don't want babies I don't think you
really associate yourself or attach
yourself with it's not even it's not
even that though but if if a woman wants
an abortion and she's not she's not
ready to have a child I she should have
a [__] abortion like you like you're
all [__] crazy they've all got
heartbeats are 5 weeks old it's a little
lump of Cs stop a minute I'm not crazy
I'm telling you a fact a scientific fact
I don't give a [__] about the scientific
facts if a woman wants an abortion they
should have a [__] abortion I'm not
saying they shouldn't however you can't
call somebody crazy for stating a fact
so scientifically a baby has they they
have a heartbeat from 5 weeks old that's
that's what I'm saying right cool you
want to deny and also I'd argue that a
majority of um abortions are not from
cont from fail and I would say it's from
like mistakes in general and 40% of
women who have abortions have had more
than one two or more yeah I would say
most of the time it's it's it's you know
sloppiness or accident it's not from the
pill you know chill up it's not from the
pill failing personally but also if
we're going to talk about like the
efficacy of contraception um I think
someone in the middle mentioned the the
pill the pill is generally the the most
popular one it's the one that generally
everyone tends to be on the the the most
effective form of contraception is the
implant which is about 99% effective but
actually natural cont contraception if
use correctly is also 99% effective so
there's always a percentage of that you
could get pregnant like imagine if you
get I'll tell you I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why I would say but it's a risk
you take yeah I would you take that risk
no have sex I'll tell you why I'll tell
you I'll tell you why I would say I
would say to my brothers hey guys stay
away from those chicks I'll tell you why
because no because I believe I believe
as a mother and a wife you're supposed
to be selfless right you're supposed to
be the kids before me and you're
supposed to love your kids more than
anything in the world and so you know my
my mother actually had an accidental
pregnancy when she was quite young but
my mother is a selfless person and she
loved that child and she gave him up for
adoption I met him when I was 22 and I
and so being and we've also adopted kids
in my family so I've been on both sides
of adoption and it's because my parents
are very selfless people they are kind
selfless people and I think when you
choose a wife and a mother the most
important trait is that she's kind and
selfless and I think and I think when
you're making decisions that are selfish
I don't think it's the best wives and
mothers also you think that there's
always a certain percentage of like bias
when it comes to for example like I hope
I'm not being insensitive by saying this
but like since you have for example
parents that want to have children but
then still choose to adopt isn't there
always some sort of like no they
actually didn't want to adopt it was
these kids were in like bad situations
and they they basically saved a lot of
their like lives if I'm being honest
because they're in really rough
situations and they took they weren't
even looking to adopt they just knew him
um but I mean everyone's bi everyone's
biased so I I mean I I just don't think
like wife and mother aborts kids can I
ask you what your opinion is on um
females that have gone through a
traumatic experience I can't remember
what you told me to say but I can't say
the word so um what what do you think
about women that have had that
experience and then they've Fallen
pregnant um well I I think that's a
really sad situation and it's less than
1% so I think it's kind of used as like
a gotcha I mean but I'm gonna I'm going
to answer just wait um so uh in that
situation I think it's best to either
keep the kid or give it up for adoption
I I would I don't never think it's right
to end a human life that's just my
opinion and so what about if that child
so and I understand what you're saying
about being selfless and bringing a
child into the world regardless but what
about then if that child has trauma
because they can't get over the fact
that you know why their mother gave them
up for adoption why didn't my mom what
you want me oh well it was because of
this this this but you know I'm still
her child sort of thing what about that
trauma you think it's okay to then adopt
a child and they're searching and
they're seeking for can I speak on this
someone who has that specific I'm
genuinely ask so that is it's a wound
that never goes away no matter how how
old you are at growing up you're always
going to think why why wasn't I wanted
so for example I was very much wanted I
was taken away by social services but
even still I'm like but why I wasn't I
wanted it's a wound that's never healed
however it's a wound I have alive and
living yeah that's the difference I'm
here yeah but you know you were wanted
so what I'm saying by someone and there
are kids I I know who people who have
been in the care system their whole life
they they would they were never found
okay if we're going to put it bluntly
they were never found they were never
chosen right yeah I'm very lucky because
I'm part of the statistic that that gets
picked you know I'm a white female who
was born who was adopted before the age
of one okay so I'm very lucky but I'm
aware there's a huge group of people
that don't have that however we have to
acknowledge every single one of us in
this room and every human being on the
planet has some kind of trauma or some
kind of wound in their life but isn't it
better that we're all
here cuz we're all going to have one
wound or one trauma one way or the other
I mean I don't know we are here but you
know for some people it's a challenge to
be here living a chall but isn't it
isn't it a leap of faith to State and to
believe that it's better to be here than
it's not to be I mean if that's how you
feel that's how I feel I thought I think
it's good to I know people that have
taken their lives because of and I would
much rather that they were here right I
would much rather they were here but
we're talking about how that person
feels and how they don't have to
feelings aren't permanent it's a
temporary solution it's a permanent
solution to a temporary problem I just
like we always go extreme no but because
you know what in the real world things
can be extremely extreme that's why
people BL their Liv even even to address
that point even if we want to speak
about people that have trauma and people
that take their lives it still comes
down to the same principle if we even
want to go religious about it this life
doesn't belong to us 100% so even people
that take their lives shouldn't be
taking their lives because it doesn't
belong to them 100% so it's even worse I
will understand you will understand that
I understand I get it but the fact of
life is that suicide as bad as it might
be is not the right choice right so if
we know that that that's true that
people shouldn't be taking their lives
so why should we even support all other
people deciding to take the life for
someone else but remember that's your
view noew I personally have the same
view but not everyone thinks like that
and all I was saying is about you know
people living with trauma and to not to
everybody I mean it's a fact I'm just
speaking facts not everyone can cope
with living with trauma and that's why
people you know do take their lives
unfortunately and and and that's down to
Destiny because at the end of the day if
someone decides okay I have this all all
this trauma and I can't live anymore and
I want to take my own life that is that
person's Destiny and that is what that
person has chosen to do it's not up to
us to now say well it would have been
better if they were not born no 100%
also can we go back to the the general
General point of it sorry to reduce
reduce it back to the the general but
Bonnie mentioned something that I
thought was really import important you
said like you know everyone just wants
to have sex yeah
clearly we wouldn't exist would of
course a natural tendenc would have only
fans the main nature of life
however so you you can have sex right of
course like I'm I'm not going to sit
here and tell you what you can and can't
do but if you let's say I don't I don't
know your personal opinion let's say
like you really don't like the idea of
having abortion you said yourself if you
was that 1% that was taking
contraception religiously you never
missed a pill you did everything right
and you got pregnant you said you'd be
human does that not indicate to you that
you're having sex with people that you
probably wouldn't want to have children
with so therefore shouldn't you be only
having sex with people that you would
see yourself having a child with
otherwise you're being negligent that
life that would then be here okay so um
I'd say 90% of my partners I would say
if I would have in the past being a
young girl especially when I was like 18
back then I was probably with guys I
shouldn't have been with that like when
you're 18 you're stupid you're with guys
you you freaking hate them so isn't that
a societal problem that we have that
we're teaching young girls that's okay
but like if I I was on the pill back
then if I would have got pregnant with
them kind of guys yes I would have been
fuming because back then naive child as
a teenager I would have been so annoyed
but like as I'm 28 if I got pregnant now
whether it was a one night stand or a
partner if I got pregnant now I would
keep it because I'm old enough and I
know that is my so what do you say now
is that your 20 28 what would you say
now to 18yearold girls who are
perhaps take the pill and work on done
but you even said yourself there's a 1%
chance even if you do it correctly you
still might so isn't it better to tell
them only have sex with people that
you're willing to have a child with no
no of course not cuz you have to
experiment to live like I feel like if
if you're going to say to people only
have experiment sexually to live no yeah
well in a way yeah I mean that's a way
to get STDs no but I feel like a part of
growing up is experimenting with
different things like some girls
experiment with girls some girls
experiment can't get prant that way so
so what so you're saying sexual
experience you you just have one partner
that you want to have a kid with and get
married to and that's it you really
don't have you only had sex with one
person that you want to marry that's
[__] [__] no obviously not the
[__] then that's what
you but you should only have sex with
someone you're willing to have a child
what's the problem with having that kind
of mentality there's nothing wrong with
that the way coming have you been like
that minute you're say say to 18y old
girls that you should have one partner I
didn't say that I said you should have
sex with someone you're willing to have
a child
with a it's not [__] do you think
it's better to have sex with men that
you don't want children with no I'm not
saying that but it's not [__]
possible not we're not all living like
that nobody [__] I you are you saying
it's
impossible I'm not saying it's
impossible I'm saying people don't [__]
I text that many people like the most
girls I speak to my my body count is
very low I don't but they're not all're
not I know I know but like what I'm
going to say to you what I'm going to
say to you is they not all people are
been like right you could I could be
with you for 80 years but you do think
when you're 18 yes you're hot and I need
to lose my virginity you don't think I'm
going to marry you but that's the thing
I think that what she's saying is I
don't know obviously you've got your
journey I think generally gener
generally you meet someone and you get
to know that person and then you decide
to take that step because you can see a
longterm or you think at the time you
know you're going to have a long one
night stand AR a things
everyone I don't want to have one night
stands you know why because I believe in
energy energy transference and I don't
want to share my energy with someone
number one I don't know where you've
been where you've come from like I'm not
in it so you can't make one mistake in
your whole life not saying you can't I'm
just saying my
preference you must have you must have
done things like this in your past
though why are we using one night stands
as a justification for giving the right
Maring people
talk the question was at 18 if as a if
you was 18 and giving an 18-year-old
advice now would you tell them that you
shouldn't have sex with anyone but the
person that you feel like but the way
you're saying it is like okay but the
fact is you know I can't justify that
because you know they're going to go and
have one night stands you're justifying
it I want I want to use a different I'm
going to use I'm going to use a
different example if I say to a
18-year-old I say hey do not get
blackout drunk that's not a good idea it
could put yourself in a situation you
don't want to be in you don't want a guy
to take advantage like like if I if I
list all the reasons do not get blackout
drunk are you guys going to argue Len
wait wait wait I actually I actually
wait wait I actually know many people
that have never lived that lifestyle I
do I know I know women I know women I
know women that were virgins on their
wedding days I know I know women yes
they exist they
exist exist yes yes yes I know women
that have never touched alcohol they
exist people make different choices and
so does it that 18-year-old might that
18-year-old might go on to become an
alcohol po I can't I can't stop her but
at least I'm giving her the correct
information and the issue we have is
we've had we've had wait wait we've had
not one not two but I would argue three
generations of women that have given the
women today bad information because we
can't say water is wet the sky is blue
don't get blackout drunks and have one
night stands that's bad that that is not
helpful noty it's not I just feel like
we need to stop basically glorifying
this like World phase cuz not everyone
needs to have a wild face in their life
like if they want to have it yeah it's
up to them
czy I'll tell you I'll tell you
something crazy though if a guy deals
drugs when he goes to jail when he's
younger okay when he talks to the
younger men he'll say stay away you you
you literally can see like interviews in
prison of men talking about this they'll
say hey young guys do not go down that
path you don't have to do that but older
women will justify doing it for younger
women older men will say hey that's a
bad path don't go down they won't
justify and say no you have to sell
drugs you have to commit crimes no
they'll give the men the right
information now some men will take that
advice and some won't they can't really
help who does but at least they have the
correct
information women will tell younger
women not to go out and be
you got compass and respect and dignity
you not
true we've spoken to we've spoken to it
depends who you talk to we've
doneen have you I don't know we we' had
hold on we this is this is episode
151 there's nothing that been said in
this room today that we're hearing for
the first time this is and this is the
thing when women speak they always think
that they the first person to come up
with this thing that they saying we hear
this every single week week in week out
we do Street interviews and Street
interviews we don't we don't cast people
we literally see random people on the
street office people strippers all sorts
of women you lot don't realize that you
all say the same exact thing I should
hope so that's a brilliant thing if
there's women saying what I'm saying no
not what you're saying what I'm saying
this narrative that's why this show
exists I'll give I'll
give I was going to make a point I was
going to make a point my point is my
point is what they saying is actually a
very good reflection of what Society is
today you don't see no but you don't see
it because probably you're in a
different Circle yeah 100 I'm not with
that I don't want to be around but I
tell you why it's a very it's this is
actually a good representation the
reality is in the Western World what we
have now is families loads of
generations have been raised without
fathers and even the women that were
raised with fathers still didn't have
fathers because their fathers had no
backbone and couldn't see anything in
the house you do you know what you're
probably absolutely right I was actually
raised by my father and he taught me
exactly but but the point I'm trying to
make is that because I've had tons of
women sit on this couch and say that
when they went to their parents to tell
them that they're going to do only fans
their parents supported them really I
feel like that must that must be rare I
feel
like M number one suppor wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait can you say that
could you say that my mom loves the do
only fans by the way my only fans is
only okay okay okay
okay so out of out of the horse's mouth
not
rare wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait okay
and the point the point I'm making is I
just went to um an event like literally
like an hour and a half before this it
was like I would argue women over the
age of 35 to 45 50 trying to figure out
how to get younger women to have more
abortions they're trying they're they
said they said in a PowerPoint that
their goal was to make then I asked this
question and then they didn't like me
too much when I started asking questions
but but but I raised my hand and I'm
like let me get this straight you want
to make it like these abortion pills
like Advil and they they said yeah they
said over the counter over now well they
want to they want to well EXA and they
want to go to countries they want to go
wait wait they want to go to countries
whose cultures don't like that and send
these abortion pills these are the older
women that we have teaching us and even
the women that maybe told women not to
sleep around often times they'll say to
never rely on a man and always have a
backup plan that does that that is very
when they say have a backup plan what do
they mean they always want women to have
a backup plan in case the marriage
doesn't work that is terrible advice I'm
sorry but if you can trust a man to have
kids with you should be able to trust
him with money why do we have why do we
why do we have a society where we said I
can trust you to be the father of my
child but I can't trust you with money
that innately says that money is more
important than family and know I think I
can agree with you if you're talking
about going into a relationship as a
whole someone you're going to have sex
with have children with and be serious
with and then of course I think that
finances should be shared I mean but I
don't see is anyone disputing that
I really I don't care I don't no sorry
could I'm saying that is a common thing
that older women say to younger women I
am not saying it's every older women but
I'm saying older women and we have you
who is 28 right I'm I older woman oh my
God my cofin ready wait I'm saying
you're older the the idea was it was
wait wait stop getting offended stop
crying all
right stop so I'm wait wait wait let me
get okay wait Jesus Christ so at 2018 is
younger than 28 you are going to know
way more at 28 than you did at 18 that
is that is enough of an age Gap to give
advice and wisdom right but by older
women there's a difference between a 28y
old and a 58y old telling me what to do
you older is older than the person
you're giving advice to Dear God dear
God I didn't say a grandma I said old
who's the oldest in the room I'll listen
to you 18 18 18 28 that's 10 years Mommy
that's 10 years right and so my point is
she was just arguing that they can't not
have a one night stand this is a trend
older women often times I'm not saying
there's not exceptions do not help
younger women this is why a lot of times
when we we do have older women on the
show and they give go ADV good advice
they go stupid
viral I've got a good example so I'm 28
my cousin a very attractive young lady
very pretty very gorgeous she's 19
messaged me the day and said I want to
start an on fans I said no freaking way
do not do not you dare I will kill you
she's like you do it I'm like but I'm 28
I've got I've got thick skin now like I
get it I take all all of the stuff that
comes with it it destroys your life when
you start it and you get over it if you
started I'm like you if you if I started
that when I was her age I don't know if
I would surv I probably wouldn't be here
so I'm like I've been the older woman
going if you understand that I'm mature
enough to tell the men to shut the hell
up and ignore it and I am Tunnel Vision
on my own life I do not give a f but
anyone says but you see but this is the
point of this is the point of the fact
that older that women typically don't
give good advice I'm giving good advice
do it no that's not good advice
understand the reality can can I land my
point you think my cin are you going are
you going to wait for me to make my
point you can go hun thank you so my
point is you said to her oh don't do it
because um uh this and that and then she
said you do it and then your response
was yeah but I have thicker skin now
that's is literally the worst thing you
can say I guess what you should say this
is and this is different between and wom
I'll tell you why if if you give me a
second and listen you will hear why if a
man is giv advice to a young person and
he's saying this is bad he's going to
tell him this is bad because simple and
he'll give him the reasons why it's bad
there is not going to be any caveat for
why it could have been good or why maybe
now it works for me it is bad it is bad
don't do it don't do it but what you're
doing is you're saying it's bad okay but
there are certain circumstances under
which it could work like for instance
when you have thicker skin that is you
have I've told you the very brief story
to what I told her I told her that I had
very me bad mental health I didn't want
to be alive when I first started it it
went very deep and I said a lot of deep
stuff you don't understand is that I
went very deep with my cousin so I've
not said this on the podcast but I'll
say it now that's good but you still put
the caveat and I'm I'm not saying this
to you specifically I'm saying because
it's a trend I've seen with women even
on different other kinds of topics like
like for instance a woman would say will
ask a question like um do you think um
sex work is good or do you think women
should be promiscuous and then she say
well for me I don't think it's a good
thing but if other women want to do it
that's fine that is the way women give
advice and that is wrong something is
your princip stand by
it can I just say something in her
defense she didn't actually say that it
was okay to do what she said is she
wouldn't have done it if she basically
if she'd known then what she knows now
she wouldn't have done it would do it
and she wouldn't advise she sorry she
wouldn't advise someone to do it and she
has had to grow thick skin but she
didn't say that anyone should do it
she's basically
say I have a question you said not at
that age
yes that age no no but I I feel like
you're kind of
picking but you didn't mean in general
you know because she's giv the age of
you've said an 18-year-old what advice
would you give you know no I don't I
don't but this is the point like if if
she put the caveat I wouldn't at that
age and that is the point that he is
making so did you did
you wait wait I'm going to let you go
but wait you guys cannot talk over the
host I've told you guys 10 times okay so
if he says I'm going to drug deal I
wouldn't do it at that age that is a
completely different message than I
wouldn't do it that is a completely you
can mean thing but like it's not what
you are saying when you communicate it
like that it gives a completely
different implication if I said oh um I
wouldn't drug deal um it can work in
some situations if you maybe are good at
avoiding cops or or very slick that is
justifying it but if you say no do not
do it do not do it do not do it that is
that is clearly being against it the
other one is excusing it in some way
even if you do not mean to therefore one
advice is better than the other yeah
100% I agree with that because we're
talking about abortion we're talking
about another life so it is your
responsibility if you're not trying to
have a baby but you're going to have a
baby with someone that you don't want to
have a baby with outside of marriage
let's say cuz that person is not secure
in your life I'm not saying your choices
are wrong I'm just saying that when it
comes to abortion you need to think of
not just yourself um you have to think
of the child and also it's not a
child literally not a child though I
think every woman should be able to
advise you know I think what you say is
right you're going to want to advise a
younger young you got to talk in I'm
sorry I think you're going to want to
advise every young girl you know not to
sleep around Etc and I think in terms of
abortion I think it's such a sensitive
topic I think each has their own and
there are reasons and there are
backgrounds that we don't know about
today and I think that it'll be very
difficult for any of us to sit here and
be like art it's just a fetus just a art
it's just a baby let's just I think you
know I don't think that any of us have
the right to comment on on abortion or
whatever not it's right because but I
agree though that you you definitely
shouldn't everyone should advise a woman
to do better and not to be but they're
not as forward though and it's it proves
it at the start of the show when we was
talking about the fact thing women don't
tend to be forward so that's why because
this is talking about the influence on
younger children growing up and how are
I don't like this idea that we can
police what people can and can't talk
about yeah like we can't have an opinion
on things that's the whole point of
podcasting is to have opinion on
everything everyone should yeah and so I
think when it comes to abortion you
certainly can't I think it's wrong I I
don't think there's any exceptions I
think it's always wrong no matter your
situation I mean you you have a unique
you have a unique wait wait you have a
unique DNA code that's separate from the
mothers and fathers that that it
determines eye this is from conception
eye color height personality traits it
it's completely different from the mom
and the dads I mean you know some people
I'm just saying I know you're going to
say that it's like very very rare but
I'm just saying there are sometimes
cases where you know people can't have
the child it's either you got you have
to take the child's life or the mother's
life yeah in that what would you say
then when it's the when it's the from
what I've read on that that's very very
rare just sit say I know wait wait Jesus
wait cuz I'm going to get to the answer
wait um it's really rare but what I
would say is that uh if it was me I
would always want the kid to live that's
just my I that's my like I just think as
a mother you're supposed to be selfless
and we have a generation of mothers that
are selfish it's me me me me first my
career first my feelings first and my my
Happ happiness first so if you got
pregnant tomorrow I would look it I I
just genuinely think when you have a kid
you're supposed to love it more than
yourself well you can't love it if
you're
dead well isn't that isn't that the
ultimate Act of Love though sacrificing
your life for like that you asked me you
asked me what I would do I think there I
think there's
some do you not think it'd be a really
sad life without a mother I yeah it
would be really sad but we we go back
does that does that mean they can't what
about if you already had a child and
then you fell pregnant again and it was
your life or that child fall pregnant I
hate that phrase like what okay she fell
over and got pregn she fell over on that
dick you be what I would do I believe
that the child's life's more important
than my own that that's what I would do
if that if I was in that situation I was
just genuinely curious yeah I think we
should just have baselines on things as
well like can't we just have a baseline
of look that's bad and then maybe we can
listen to if it's grape or whatever but
that's the I'm just saying the Baseline
rules not making rules Jes many
different scenar so you don't think that
the Baseline is bad I'm going to start
making bad rules having abortion yeah in
just is it bad is it bad forget the
scenario just for a second is it bad for
me personally opinion I think depends on
situation that's what he's asking but
see but this is the point but that's my
opin I we know you're entitled to an
opinion we know like like duh
obviously but the whole point is like
women can't say that things are bad so
it's not they don't give even older
women don't give good information to
younger women that we can't even say
killing your kid is bad you know what's
even you know what's even funnier and
it's funny that a lot of women don't
even realize this the effect of abortion
the effect abortion has on women is
actually even more devastating than
going through with the pregnancy m
and and it's funny how and it's crazy
because it's crazy sound from experience
that you're saying this um I'm an adult
male who can do research into things I'm
interest you're not a woman though
you've never been through it how can you
say unless you've been through it know
can I there's actually research there's
actually research out there's actually
research research does nothing towards
the real thing though I ask yeah go on
now go on it's like facts resear there's
there's effect that abortion has on
women there's psychological effect
there's physical damage effect there's
the fact that you might never be able to
have kids again so it's funny how the
reason why you don't know that this
exists is because they purposely don't
push it out because they want more
abortions and that's why you don't know
not because it doesn't exist because
it's because you're
ignorant you know it is true that's why
you thought that they were just tissues
because they don't actually tell you
that how what consists of the procedure
do you know where contraception and plan
parent parthood and abortion came from
where do you know what Eugenics is
yes that's what it is it's literally to
eradicate people it was invented as a
form of genocide yeah they're not going
to push that out there cuz then they're
not going to be able to sell it are they
so everyone who was abortion but some
people need it that's ridiculous as only
go I actually can't
believe I think we're talking about
women a lot here I think often in
circumstances what we get in
age is that a woman would get pregnant
and be willing to Mother the child Etc
but a man would ask that that child how
many abortions do you I'm put out get
well but why are they sleeping with
those L [__] women I tell you I'm
just putting out that they're sleeping
with each other you know there's
probably equal liability on each side no
I I think women have the option to be on
birth control Plan B and we
contraception but but the thing is the
only person that has all the information
when it comes to get getting pregnant is
the woman so the woman knows if she's on
contraception the woman knows if she's
going to take a plan B the man she could
lie about that to the man if the condom
and the woman the woman knows if he's
wearing a condom or not right so woman I
understand but the man doesn't know for
sure if she's on birth control so I'm
saying so that's why I think the woman
has more responsibility because she know
she knows if she's ovulating or not yeah
that's only three days a month
that hold on
who who who ends up with with the baby
who goes through more of the traumatic
um hold on who goes through more being
pregnant so after we've had sex yeah who
goes through more me or you well this is
why your decision influences a female
isn't it and I'm sitting here I'm trying
to I'm trying to figure out who goes
through more who's respon who who should
be more responsible of cont woman and
that's what I'm saying this is why I'm
wondering how some men influence a
woman's decision about whether they
should keep a baby whether they should
not keep a baby when in fact they both
made it both took the same risk I don't
think it's fair but I'm saying if if
you've been deliberately dece it's
different but the woman the woman has
all the choice so the woman gets to
choose whether or not she's on birth
control the woman gets to choose whether
or not she's on the plan the woman who
okay wait okay okay question question
wait wait who question whose choice is
it to be on birth control or not man or
woman the woman's that's okay okay okay
please one word answerers please whose
choice is it to take the plan B man or
woman a woman would typ the pil okay
whose choice is wait wait wait whose
choice is it to get an abortion the
women's okay it should be the woman okay
whose choice is it to give up the kid
for adoption or not the woman's
definitely okay so the woman has more
Choice therefore it comes with more
responsibility is it the does for the
woman I agree with who generally gets
child support men or women I agree with
you that point my point is that men
influence and women in their
decision control SE who controls
[Music]
sex
participants it depends on the anyway
we're not going to go there but no
definitely I think that you know it is
definitely the woman's responsibility
I'm not going to lie
because can I just say something hold on
hold
on
she's trying to make a point that is why
I'm saying that you know to have um
frivolous sex with people yeah like okay
that is your decision whether or not you
want to but ultimately that comes with a
risk you know of you falling pregnant it
is up to you whether you have the child
I've known people that have lied to men
and said that they're on contraception
you know and unfortunately there's there
are a lot of men out there that have
children I'm not saying they couldn't
have strapped up but at the same time
you know it's your body you're the one
that's going to carry the child you know
what I mean so you have to take
responsibility as
to who you're lying down with yeah you
know you do you you do women do control
that ACC you control sex women control
sex simp come on I think there's no
black and white answer they do they do I
think there's no black and white answer
I think it's you know there's number of
different scenarios here as to what can
happen I want to point I I want to point
out something whenever it's like an
answer that makes women look bad the gut
reaction is always there's no black and
white answer like that's always that's
always I agree that it's bad if a woman
influences a child as to say that it's
okay to be having sex unprotected I
think that's bad I acknowledge that but
I'm just saying that in in general terms
that when it comes to abortions and sex
and having unprotected sex I think it's
very black and white and you would need
to know the circumstances of each and
every well they have it they survey
women and the reasons they got abortion
98% are elective I me and this is from
the NHS website but I mean ultimately
it's you know the woman houses the child
so it is her decision it doesn't matter
you know ultimately if a a man could sit
there and tell you I don't want a child
or you know it's not the right time or
whatever it is that they're going to say
and try and convince you till they're
blew in the face but ultimately is your
decision whether on you go and have that
procedure it is okay um we're going to
go to the next one so now imagine
imagine I Want I Want I Want I Want I
Want I Want to point out I want to point
out I want to point out if I had a list
of what I I might try this one show a
list of what men want or what women want
from men I just I don't think we would
be this money dick this many a big [__]
[__] yeah I don't okay now
all right all right all to buy my all
right so the next thing that might that
this is something the next thing I have
is something that men do compromise on
in 2023 they really do oh really but it
would be a PL compromise that's new to
me
well sorry sorry one second um ladies
I'm just going to give one more warning
please let's try and just be decent here
like if she's trying to make a point
we're just over talking and then no
people are home not hearing anything all
right so yeah I get it it's a
conversation we want to all chip in but
let's just try and be civil here thank
you okay so thank you King so all right
this is something that men do compromise
in
2023 yes I know you're your guys are
kidding around and and saying men don't
well men compromise oh they compromise a
lot the average woman's 170
pounds 90% you know one out of Three's
had an abortion one out of Three's had
an stb D and 90% have been on birth
control at some point in their life so a
100 years ago the average woman was 120
pound pounds and would give him seven
children now the average woman gives
1.5 so men do men do compromise and men
are compromising on this in
2023 but this is pretty nice if they get
it let's Point let's bring it up maybe
some domestic
skills men men would really they do
enjoy when the women can cook clean and
really have
traditional maybe maybe we're a nanny or
something I've heard I've heard from the
guys they like the nannies they're nice
you know good with the kids domestic
skills isn't that like standard don't
you have to cook no food to eat like to
live you have to clean how many people
come on here I don't understand you be I
mean well if you look at the N like
takeout orders are going up you know I
mean you can eat out a million times but
it's not it's not yeah but this is the
world we've created for example like my
My Generation gen Z we we've grown up in
a world where you got fast food on your
doorstep in seconds you got Amazon
delivery the next day how old are you
Sor I'm 23 oh so my daughter's 21 and
she cooks every single day and she's got
that from from you though I presume and
she cleans every day my point is but not
everyone is like that I don't know so I
I'll say I'm saying a lot of people who
come here especially my generation will
say like oh
uh I'm not going to cook I'm not going
to clean I'm they don't have that they
don't have that but fast food tastes so
plastic like it doesn't tast People
season it yourself mean I agree with you
not everyone can cook though really like
some people are generally really bad in
is a basic skill to
have there are some people that can't
just it's hold on it's a skill you don't
stand in a kitchen with your watch them
season up
the never had that like when I was I
have a question I have a question do you
really please God please God do you
think do you really think in 2023 most
women under 30 know how to cook yeah
yeah I'm being honest with you so you're
teaching me something because to me
that's we we would we would even my
14-year-old can call yeah no that's not
that's not the not I think it depends
standard no I would teach my little one
the most popular the most youen had that
common if youen that then the most
popular phrase in 2023 is I Don't Need
No Man and you you really think these
women let's let's think let's think of a
popular song Why would this resonate
with so many people I don't cook I don't
clean like why like the only reason
songs get popular is because people
resonate with
them yeah is that like C or something
there's a reason this oh you know don't
act like you didn't know don't act like
you didn't know I have to think about it
for a second that for but that's that
says it all no but what's so funny is
offet posted a video of her actually
cooking and cleaning why are you lying
to people it's
even yes that's what happens these these
these music influences tell you all of
these to the left to the left and all
wom telling young women things that they
don't listen to that and think that
that's real life she tell to put the box
in the left and goes back to JayZ after
yeah I mean that's crazy I don't believe
that that should be I don't believe that
that should be real life this is the
world we live in like saying Instagram
is real My Generation thinks their
Instagram page is a
personality I know more more guys now
but becoming a little bit more willing
to do house chores they want to like
split the chores they want like I my
brother's like 16 he's like when I get
married like she doesn't have to cook oh
I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll tell
you the men I'm going to tell you about
this new Dynamic we're going to see I'm
going I'm going to I want I want to tell
you about this new Dynamic so we're
right now we have a lot of women that
are earning more and more
and I would argue they're in mostly
useless jobs that we don't really need
like HR and really diversity hires like
if you see Twitter before and after they
hired all these women in Tech that
really like were kind of useless and
then they fired them when the rubber
hits the road that's how you can tell if
they're really needed or not but not all
not all there are some high high earning
women that are very smart and
intelligent too and what you're going to
see with those women I see this a lot
with lawyers actually is what the
lawyers will do I'm I'm going to use
this example as um they tend to date the
lower earning men CU a lot of the lawyer
chicks can't get the men at the law
firms or men that make equal money
because they tend to be more
argumentative and that's not typically
what men want in no offense but wait
wait please wait thank you and so what I
see they date they tend to go for looks
so it's like personal trainers
entertainers and musicians that just
seems to be the three they like to go
for now and you're going to see this
Dynamic where young men will realize
that if they just get jacked and learn
how to cook and clean that they can just
date one of these high earning women and
that's way easier yeah I think for me
when it comes to standards and men and
if you're a lawyer and you got these
standards I think for me I am but I've
got I don't I don't have standards like
that for me I still look for and I can't
speak on behalf of all female lawyers
but on on behalf of me I feel like I'm
successful in what I do but I don't look
for a man that can match my success but
more so for a man that I can connect
with and that's PS at success and then
who we could build with together as
opposed to saying he needs to earn this
much money he needs to match meaning I
think those are unrealistic expectations
and that's not what I do exactly that's
that's my point so women typically High
earning women cannot get the men on
their level they typically cannot get
men that earn as much as they do
typically so what I see them tend to go
for is they go they call it connection
but it really just means he's hot and he
can talk to me for that I mean I I look
for somebody that could not finished
yeah I'm not I'm not talking about you
personally okay but go ahead I know I'm
just saying that me personally talking
about me personally because this is
obviously about lawyers and so forth um
I'm just saying that in terms of me I do
not I'm not one of them lawyers that say
okay I earn x amount of money so I need
a man that can earn double that amount
of money I need a man that can respect
what I do encourage me in what I do and
simply be there and have the connection
and that's it and
and typically they're goodlook which
goes back to my point oh yeah would they
would be goodl look exactly for me
anyway but everyone has their own
opinion I agree with
that so you so you you backed up what
exactly the trend that I see now and
what I'm going to I you are going not
the majority of men but you're going to
see a group of men that realize it is
easier to just learn domestic skills and
find a high earning woman than to get
get a job but what is that I don't of
money and I don't understand how the
domestic skills and the looks of a man
are relating here well because because
they typically the women that are high
earning women I see and just this is
just from doing all of these shows and I
just see patterns of behavior and what I
found is a lot of high earning women
tend to pick some sort of musician you
know it's usually the hot guy with the
guitar um other times it's the trainer
is the most common one that I see a
personal trainer some
and and I want to tell you another thing
so typically typically typically if
women have a gut reaction and say I hate
that person or that that job how would
they hate that person if they hadn't
dealt with them in the past youd have to
spend time with them and so at some
point usually those chicks have dated or
spent time with personal trainers about
men with only fans skills um what do you
explain that you're saying you have to
spend time with them to get to know them
I feel like you don't no no what I don't
understand the question like you're
saying you have to spend time with a
personal trainer to get to know them and
have a relationship with them no is that
not what you no well I think I think men
men will spend time with an only fans of
girl you know what I mean for sure they
won't even die that that's not the point
though that's not the
point no no I just I find so women will
say oh I hate insert and it's always a
profession that women tend to love so I
hate bouncers I hate DJs I hate I hate
personal trainer and it's always like a
a profession that tends to get women and
usually they hate them because they've
dealt with them at some point and they
had like 10 chicks you know I get what
you're saying and I think that a lot of
okay I I'll just speak on behalf of me
because I can only really speak on
behalf of me but I have realistic
expectations I think if there's a
professional like you say a lawyer or
something out there's got expectations
that a man ears more than her or a man
does this I think that's unrealistic and
she's not going to match it or she wants
a man in the gym I have obviously my
personal preferences but for me I would
like a man that I can you know you want
a man that you can connect to I don't I
don't mind cooking I like cooking
cleaning as well as going out and
providing you know and I think that's
that's what I like and I think that's
balanced I'm not out there saying I need
a man that goes to the gym I won't lie
but then but the problem is I think what
she's trying to say is is then you those
type of women are then going to get the
men who are looking for women like you
who are successful because they can't be
bothered to to be more successful if
again it goes down to connection I think
I would know if there was a man that was
with me just for my sucess but that's
what she's trying to say well and that's
that's the the whole point is women what
do women pick for right
me because it's almost like wa wait wait
wait so what what do women pick for it's
usually looks right or money or maybe
humor right right I'm not one person
that looks for money I'm one that looks
for connection care stability do you
usually feel that with men you're not
attracted to feel what the things that
you listed with men that you're not
attracted to no I've got a specific type
but doesn't everyone have a specific Ty
exactly but this is my point that's what
I'm saying High earning women tend to
choose for looks because they tend to
not compete when it comes to money
because the men that earn a lot of money
typically don't want argumentative women
which tend to be the women that make a
lot of money not all there's exceptions
but in general
I agree looks is 100% important but not
looks alone though I couldn't have a man
who's got the looks and he's [__]
everywhere else have you have you have
you ever experienced right have you ever
experienced like being with a guy and he
just actually looks after you and you
don't have to work you can if you want
but you don't have to have you ever
experienced that yeah wish cuz I'm
telling you
now give him my
number I actually generally have had a
man that wanted me and you still wanted
to work what he wanted me to do is give
up my career and let him him be the sole
income earn and bring that in but for me
I mean I did have a man that did that
but for me it was about doing what I
wanted and what I was passionate about
and being independent cuz recently I was
I was with someone who had that mindset
yeah and then they um experienced s like
what they would call it and all that
independent woman thing went out the
window mhm it depends independent woman
I would like to get happily married but
my priorities a different so my
priorities are not that I need a man to
build me up but my priorities are that I
will build me up I will build my kids up
and I will do what I got to do for me
and make myself
successful I can I say something can I
say something you know what it is it's
cuz you've got a passion I think maybe a
woman that doesn't have a passion that
she wants to pursue then maybe no she
had passion she
just not passion in general did she have
something she wanted to purs independent
woman yeah could
retire that's not passions had passions
made money all I'm talking about had
passions I'm talking about a passion for
example when you were a kid yeah what
did you want to be me yeah as a kid
footballer right so no so what I'm
saying but but but the but the best but
the best women want to be mothers yeah
and the one that chill the best women
best why can't you be both why can't you
because you cannot have everything but
you can if you work hard Who who okay
wait wait wait
wait Jesus stop stop that's crazy Jesus
like I've warned you so many times stop
overt talking
me oh my God all right you you said you
can have both who's watching the kids
when you're working so the way it works
is that because and I don't want to
sound a type away but I'm just going to
say it as it is anyway but if you work
hard enough and you are successful as I
am I work for myself so I am able to
have a good work life balance where I
can provide for my children be there for
them take them but also go in the office
when I need to and that could be when
they're in school and when they are in
extra education and things like that but
I'm still there for my children and I
think that that is my priority as
opposed to finding a man that could
carry me or anything but you see this is
this is um a legal consultant so I uh
represent wait let him let him I want to
address what you said so like the
reality of life is like she said you
can't have everything and this is the
problem a lot of women face women think
they can have everything thing now the
first point is I have everything I have
can you can you stop can you stop um
interrupting me um so the point is it's
literally impossible to have everything
even as men we know this you have to
make sacrifices in life absolutely so I
agree with that now here's the thing a
dynamic that love women don't understand
about relationships is relationships
only work when there is a masculine and
a feminine energy mhm
now what you women tend to always say is
you want a masculine man that is
feminine at the same time which is
impossible and doesn't exist now if and
I said masculine and feminine note I
didn't say man and woman because in
lesbian relationships if you notice
there's always the masculine and The
Feminine not always but yeah the ones
that work always that's the point so
that's so if the
woman now has the masculine energy what
you're going to find is she's always
going to attract feminine men a
masculine woman is never going to
attract a masculine man but what should
be and this is the reason why women tend
to fall into the same traps over and
over again because you go you you want
to have everything so you chase success
thinking that you can get success and
get the man you want I don't see for me
they don't go hand in hand okay let me
respond if if you're finished though
because I want you to finish okay for me
I don't chase success to get the man
that I want okay I chase success because
I have expectations that I set for
myself and a life that I want to provide
my children with or without a man by my
side and so I work for that in terms of
a masculinity in a man and provide of
course you just answered my question
just answer my but I have a question
wait did you say you're not married
though right I'm not married no but wait
how old are you again 34 but that that's
the point you can't have everything no
but I'm not asking for everything no but
but that's my point is typically you
have to make a sacrifice and in your
case you don't have a husband and that's
okay and that's okay I'm not I'm not you
know to each their own but the point is
you don't have it all you can't have
everything ABS but who says that I'm
looking for everything well but the
point is earlier you earlier you said
you could have it all and I'm saying you
cannot have it all you want it back what
I've always said is that I aim to
provide my children and myself with a
certain type of lifestyle without
relying on any man if I'm meet a man I
get married then great but I'm not going
to sort of wait hold back and then sort
of do it but that's the whole point is
like the cost is your children the co
because the who who is hurt the most in
this situation the kids that don't have
a dad in the home who said they don't
have a dad in the home I thought you
said you're single am I wrong that
doesn't mean they don't have a dad he
does he live with you he doesn't live
with me but that's that's the point it
is better for kids to have both parents
in always because you need to know the
personal situation of the relationship
so the majority the majority of breakups
70% um only 30% are um I forgot what
they called it but the argumentative
ones 70% like are not aru implying that
I'm argumentative I don't I don't know
no I said most of breakups are not
argumentative ones I if you if that's
that I don't know you but okay I feel
like you are yeah I you know what I like
to do you know what I like to argue for
what I think is right and what I believe
in and what I think is the wrong thing
to do and you know that's just in my
line of work and that's why I'm good at
what I do I understand that but that's
the point it came at a cost and the cost
is there's no
relationship I mean the thing is I'm not
willing to go into my personal
relationship on here but what I can tell
you is that my children are not at a
loss but actually in a better position
if you are in a relationship with a
mother and father and it's not a great
position to be in you don't know all the
circum
it wouldn't be
good I'm not even talking I'm not even
I'm not even sorry what to talk again
sorry getting
L I feel like on the sof just getting
lost I just want to ask like can we go
back to what's going on I feel lost no
no wait you guys okay I I don't then
shut up until you you can understand you
know what's happening you know what's
happening they are so used to getting
attention that when the attention is not
on them understand it this is this is
we're talking about something and you're
literally derailing the conversation
just because you want the camera to
be like literally just five times and
told shut up the whole time I haven't
told you to shut up once you told me to
shut up earlier twice I have I haven't
You' literally said to us stop talking
every time we how does how does stop
talking shut up right okay I think we're
going to leave
yeah feel like a enough I feel I'm just
sting not talking this is too much is
too
much
bye oh thank God okay okay but but you
see my point most people can't have
everything I see your point I agree with
your point yeah the point is the point
is that you always have to sacrifice
something of course sacrifice time
exactly exactly that's that's the whole
point is you can't have everything but
who said that they're going for
everything I didn't say that is you said
something along those lines earlier it
didn't say I'm going for everything I
said I'm going for the most the best
life I can give my children with or
without a man and also not even just
about my children but but the best life
is two parents in the home that's the
best life that's see let me just let me
just point something Point Blank period
there are no better outc up there are no
better outcomes there are no no better
wait wait wait wait wait there are no
better outcomes for children than having
two parents in the home you see coming
from a no no no one sec coming from a
wealthy individual who's been brought up
into their parents well there no better
there's no better there's no better
situation than two healthy parents in a
healthy relationship what's what what's
what's a better solution wouldn't it be
better to work it out and figure out a
way to get the get a absolutely wait can
you guys let me finish a sentence thank
you wouldn't it be better for you to
figure out how to get along than to
separate in general absolutely if you
can do that then great thank you thank
you if you can do that that's amazing
why is it so
impossible can can I just say can cuz I
need to understand because I just feel
like I like you know in the real
world people come from all different
types of backgrounds yeah but the fact
is that not every relationship is
healthy and if you're in a relationship
for example where a man is beating the
crap out of you minority no no no no no
no no
no stop stop stop stop stop no I'm
saying no because I told you no
exceptions we're talking about the rule
yeah I'm talking about the real world no
no I'm talking about the rule we're
talking about the majority of
relationships I mean every every time
this whole show every time we try to
have a conversation about General
relationships you keep bringing up cuz
you're talking about statistics and I'm
talking about
the can I say something are you saying
that most men beat their
part can I say
something we're talking about General
can I say something in general yeah go
on can I say something in general yeah
go all right in general yeah I'm
somebody that can relate with a lot of
people okay and I'm saying that speaking
to a woman I don't think a a high high
powered
attorney it's not your show okay but I
thought you was on here to intera and
listen to opin I will give you I don't
when
stop chill out chill out all right I
don't I don't think that a high-powered
attorney is the typical situation of
Amer or UK women go ahead I'm just
literally trying to say that isn't it so
that I mean I think I've even lost my
point now but I'm just trying to say
that isn't it a point that if you if
you're sort of working hard and that's
what you're doing you're providing for
your kids you're providing whether they
got if they haven't got both parents in
their life there's obviously reasons for
it I think coming from you I've done a
little bit of research and I see that
you raised by both parents who are very
wealthy and you're here today with your
successful podcast which is great but I
don't think that you're experienced
enough to talk about children that are
born into single Parenthood or the
reasons or to explore that I have
experience both both living in not a
wealthy childhood but then in being
successful so I'm able to relate and I
feel like you're not able to relate
what's all right what's more important
what's more important money or
parents parents
okay I would also healthy I would also
argue that healthy parents under two
things if you're not in an actual solid
foundation of a relationship why are you
having kids with that person or giving
that person kids in the that is the most
naive question I've ever heard naive can
I just say that I you're literally some
people in a relationship for 10 15 years
and the statistics of them in 10 15
years not having children is very low
and so if you're that naive to us to not
acknowledge why are why are you with
someone from for 10 15 years because if
it's not a healthy relationship nothing
starts off as an unhealthy relationship
because then you signs then you would
avoid it is of
course 10 10 to 15 years people will
only show you what they want to show you
you know you be surprised change and I
think and this is what I'm saying yeah I
agree I think when you come from like
why you why do you guys always make
excuses for bad decisions why can't we
just
it'sit wait wait wait wait why do you
guys always have excuses for bad
decision why can't we just admit what's
the bad decision wait wait wait like how
do you guys not able to listen to a
sentence and not interrupt we give you
one rule before the show don't interrupt
the host that's it it's not that hard no
everyone else can follow it but you guys
okay why do you guys keep giving why do
you keep giving excuses for every bad
decision and why can't we just talk
about in general it is better to have
two parents in the home and in general
it is bad to leave I think because in
general there's a lot more to it than to
looking at it with a tunnel vision and
saying when you're brought up with a
silver spoon in your mouth it's saying
in general this is how it is when I
think in reality what does what does
money have to do with family yeah what
does money like this is the biggest this
is the biggest this is the biggest like
lie it's a western ideology because
here's the thing you were saying
something about um growing up in uh for
I was born in Nigeria I was born and
raised in Nigeria I only moved to this
country in 2019 the reality is when see
families that even living in
poverty like abject poverty and they
stick together money is not an issue
they don't have mental health issues
they don't have any of this crazy [__]
we have in this in the UK and the US
they grow up fine a lot of them
sometimes you could see kids coming from
like poor income backgrounds actually
going growing up to actually do
something with their lives and become
better but the point is the problem is
when we say when women say oh
um uh people healthy relationships I
have an issue with that statement
because the reality is if you know a lot
about families there is no family that
is healthy there is none women keep
chasing this idea of they want to have
the perfect relationship of the perfect
man before they can stay in their
marriage there is no perfect
relationship there is no perfect man
everybody has their problem we are all
hum we all have traumas absolutely
actually and I want and I want and I
want wait wait wait wait and I want to
point something out guys this is what I
mean when this is bad advice this is bad
advice from older women 34 wait
3442 and you're G wait we didn't give
any adice oh my and because when you are
talking about the decisions that younger
women will make you are giving them
cop-outs you're saying it depends they
need to have a healthy relationship
instead of giving us the right
information and the right information is
it's wrong it is wrong is your advice
that is your advice okay cuz I'm trying
to understand you and I can actually
understand a lot your points but is your
advice to say that you should maintain
an unhealthy relationship for the sake
of the children which I I experience in
my word a lot of I instruct a lot of
psychiatrist and psychologists to
examine my clients and when I do a lot
of it comes from their background and
the sort of relationship and household
that they brought up okay so my my
advice is to if you are in an unhealthy
relationship to figure out how to make
it healthy what about that's that wait
great and and I think people throw in
the towel too soon I agree I agree with
that and I think it's because older
women give us excuses I think that is
why women wait because women respond to
social shame very quickly women like
that's why why do you think we we change
the fashion trend so quick women respond
very quickly to media and social shame
so we have a culture that bails out
women of our bad decisions by telling
them they're not bad and older women do
this
then you have a bunch of single mothers
who make excuses for their poor
decisions can I just say I agree can I
just say IE
completely however can I just say though
reality is different yeah because
reality is different this this
isn't you you literally
cannot say that yes I can it's all no I
mean you can say whatever you want to
say and ultimately this is your show and
we all have to be
do you understand what I'm saying no cuz
it is what it is but
however like your your life isn't so cut
and dry it's not it's really not
relationships aren't so cut and dry and
that's typically what women say that's
typically I do so many of these shows
guys this is literally
showsit can you give us the ideal advice
wait us advice wa wait wait wait wait my
lord it's like what I I don't know how
any guys's in a relationship with you
guys you can't get a
sentence
we give you we give you one rule we give
you one rule one
rule oh my gosh okay so I don't even
remember what I was talking about what
do you guys think what do you guys wait
it's just to say that advice is
sometimes I want I want to hear from you
guys that's all okay let's go to let's
go to the next one let's go to the next
rule I'm so
ex talking nobody asked the men
like we just
beening well at least at least they know
you know they got a good idea [__] you
know you know I've had so many opinions
but I was just like okay this is not I
know you now you deserve to talk my man
cuz go goe goe go ahead goad no I mean
it's just that I don't even want to go
back to the topic of like abortion and
stuff that that's when it was
from no this one was domestic skills
sorry but like it's just like cuz I feel
like when you talk about a lot of things
that have to do especially related to
like having children and abortion and
whatnot like why is why is the opinion
of the man is like is not relevant like
if he wants to be a father and he
genuinely wants to have a daughter or or
a son right cuz I'm I'm not ashamed to
say this I'm 27 and I've caught myself
the other day just having this thought
in my head I was like I wish I had a
daughter you know and it's it's nothing
wrong with it so it's like if I was put
in that situation why am I not allowed
to voice my opinion yeah like
you are you know so it's like because
the modern day narrative is her body her
choice it fails to acknowledge like what
you said that it takes two to turn and
go it's it's two people but
unfortunately that's the world that that
we live in men are basically second
class citizens friends that unfollowed
me because I voed my opinion or
something like that well I don't think
you should stop doing that 100% voice
your opinion yeah but you have an
opinion you want to give no my opinions
have been quite clear today to H
I just want to say though that in terms
of what we're saying we're answering the
questions as opposed to you're not
asking can you give advice for the Youth
out obviously the idal advice is one
thing but in reality is something else
and it's not possible for a woman or a
man to anticipate what sort of
relationship they're getting or how it's
going to turn out after a number of
years but all you could do is work with
it and with the children as a priority
if it's unhealthy then you got to leave
and but you can make good but you can
make but make good choices abely exactly
you don't have to choose to leave you
don't have to choose to be a single
mother you don't these are all these are
all choices what if let's hypothetically
let's give some scenarios and to catch
you on this point so what if you the
woman doesn't decide to leave but the
male then decides to leave should she
throw in a towel or continue to be
everything that she should be why did
why did he leave because of the woman
you
saying I didn't I didn't say anything I
asked the the question why why do you
get because the relationship is not
healthy I think okay but why why isn't
it healthy because a number of reasons
it could be what are the I you can't
give me a fake scenario and not give me
give scenarios okay give me the reason
it could be for the Mal or the woman if
either the M or the woman is for example
um cheating having an affair or if the M
or the woman cuz the woman could be
violent as well is violent in the
relationship so in this scenario what's
happening any one of them you're you're
talking generally for everything I'm
trying to be real okay I'm trying to be
real I'm try I'm trying to I'm trying to
but you keep giving me a couple I need a
situation what is the situation be all
of them but what is you made up the
situation so what is it what is the so
he's hitting her she's hitting him uh
it's just unhealthy it's an unhealthy
relationship notal that's violence AB
but then but then should you stay
together for the sake of the children
for the children to witness that or
should you aim for better and maybe you
work better outside of the relationship
coopar guting than you doing Under One
Roof I just think that if that's
happening where people have got to the
point where they're having blows with
each other I just feel like there must
have been some sort of sign somewhere
even if it's not physical you knew
somewhere that this was going to get
physical at some point like and normally
signs and then somebody so what you're
saying is somebody goes into
relationship and says okay this
relationship is going to be toxic I can
see I'm going to have children and that
my partner's going to leave me in 10
years no no I'm not saying that I'm
I'm saying there's normally signs that
this person has those kind of traits is
what I'm saying you can't tell me that
sometimes but say most of the time they
have signs and people choose to ignore
my question is always did your dad like
him and the answer is typically no
typically so if you didn't get your dad
if you're if you're we know if you
didn't get your dad involved with
helping pick your partner what if you
here's the thing dated I've never gotten
to that stage like where somebody like
fully like a girl came up to me and said
okay let's go and just meet my father
meet my family I don't think that's
something that happens now but they
should bring that back though yeah I me
I know but I'm saying like it would be a
good thing right if you want to have if
you want to have a kid like wouldn't it
be good to just say hey family is this a
good person what about if you don't have
a family though well whose fault is that
typically if you're born in into if your
parents are by but but I'm going but I'm
going back to it typically the women
leave typically that goes back to women
leaving if I'm a child and both of my
parents died so I have no guidance now
now this now this hypothetical is an
orphan it's hypothe there's a lot the
fact is there's a lot of hypothetical
examples there is how many people their
parents why is this in abused or like
this it could be worst orphan in
existence
100% the point is we can't speak out on
for everyone cuz there's literally okay
but okay as an adult having a
conversation do we not know that we are
not talking about every single person
does everybody know that yeah so why do
you guys keep bringing this up we know
it's the exception we know we know
there's exceptions we've said this so
many times so if they are they are their
parents have died and they're beating
each other up to the inch of death yeah
but that no no no but
listen I back I'll back both them leave
those are those are circumstan I'm
because I feel like if you're in a
happily married environment otherwise
you're not going to separate unless
there's one of these exceptions most of
most of the reasons just like they just
know crazy I know I know people that
have worked through abuse I know people
genuinely that have worked through it
that is good that's the goal I know
people I know people that have worked
through cheating I know people that have
worked through toxic relationships but
the problem is we're told you can't work
through these things and if it's
unhealthy it can never become healthy
and the best option is to leave when
generally wait wait when generally and
and when generally the best option is to
work it out I think if you let me just
point something out but you see and this
this goes back to the initial point we
made of how we give advice because the
reality is you just said you don't agree
with it right agree with what like you
don't agree that the first option is to
leave that you should work through
things no you should try and work but my
point is that it's not possible no
that's my point and that's my point too
so you you do agree that you should walk
through things but everything you've
been arguing here has been against that
yeah no that was just it
has because every time she says
something about well you should stay
then you bring up you try to for reason
why we give an example
how if you said straight lace do you
think if you said it in this way that do
you think that you should work on a
relationship up until the point you know
if it it can be worked out should you
work on it 100% I think if you can make
something make it
work if it cannot be worked out if it is
not healthy I'm saying then that is not
the best thing I gave I gave you the
best answer make it healthy no but the
point is the point is the point is but
you can't you're saying it like you can
just make it healthy the point is the
point is the point is if you do not the
point is the message that needs to be
out there what you're saying the message
needs to be out there if it
it work if
it yeah that's it no but you see that
that is given yet no listen it's reality
one no it's not it's really not it's
reality because that's what we've made
it no the reality is the reality is is
for instance we all know that selling
drugs is bad right so if for instance we
know that um selling drugs is bad and we
say selling drugs is bad that is the Bas
line it doesn't mean that it doesn't
mean that
I can I can still go out there and meet
a little boy who tells me his story and
he tells me all he went through and the
reason and I could empathize with him on
a specific level on a oneon-one level
but you would never hear me come out and
say well there should be situations
where I can understand that selling
drugs is bad because that is a wrong
message to pass even though it's
true different but it is the same it's
the same concept no it isn't Evena I
would I would argue it's worse oh my God
it's absolutely worse to break up a
family because the kids
suffer But but so why are you arguing
for every excuse to let kids every
excuse no I am not what I'm saying is I
agree if if it come work out then yes
work it out I'm a great believer of
keeping families together 100% all I'm
saying perod
allod literally I said I said this at
the start of the show just have a
baseline this is bad and then yes there
might be other reasons why you might
leave but just have a baseline it's bad
do you mean say what we want you to say
and then end it there you
mean reality let me ask let me ask you a
few questions regard reality focus on
the hypothetical perfect no no no I'm
going to ask some questions then yeah
just yes or no uh uh answers right is
abortion
bad like I said here we go right so this
is that's why
it's yes or no in general in general is
abortion bad not everything is black and
white in life can I ask you a question
can I just ask everyone a question how
many people in this room have children
how many of you have children okay you
have children how many of you have ever
been in a relationship where you've got
into the relationship you thought it was
going to be healthy for example and that
person maybe turn out to be then
indifferent and it didn't work out
how many yeah is anyone in all my
relationships there's always been signs
that's what I was going to say always
been signs happily are you happily
married I'm not oh is anyone in here Mar
that well to be no is anyone in here
mared no one's going to be married look
it we're in a post I can give you the I
can give you the numbers we're in a
post-marriage society I'm not I give you
I'm no no I'm I'm saying like under 40
people generally aren't married I'm
going to I'm going to get it back though
I have to ask people to Mar to like to
you have to get someone to ask you which
what does that mean what does that mean
I have to get someone to ask
me ask as well about like people's
backgrounds because I'm just cuz
everything is about statistics who cares
about backgrounds the question wait the
question the question the question is is
the question is is the information true
I don't care who's saying it or what
their background is I don't care no it's
it's not important is what is wait wait
what is important is is the information
true I think I I don't know anything
about anyone in this room except wait
wait I don't know anything about anyone
in this room I have no idea what your
backgrounds are I I just want to know
what is true and what is not true and we
can never get to that because we're too
busy arguing about the exception think
it's arguing I literally think if we're
talking about in general what's the best
advice to give to an 18-year-old in
general what's the best family life you
can provide for a children we would all
agree I think what we're simply doing is
exploring those
minorities of what's that that's not
always possible
think we we say but what did we what did
we didn't we I had I had a whole thing
earlier where I said everybody knows as
an adult there are exceptions right but
why okay okay okay okay because that's
not what we do here we talk about the
rules I can tell you why you shouldn't
expl minorities and it's it's it's
literally scientific like the brain
doesn't understand negatives and this is
what people don't understand when you
try to bring up things that are little
and insignificant the point is that you
tend to focus on that there's a reason
why the loudest M um majority on the
social media is actually the minority of
people let me tell you something okay in
my job I represent the minorities so
when I'm here I'm not here to talk about
those that are fed off a silver spoon or
whatever those that are wealthy but I'm
here to talk about minorities in my job
I represent the minorities and those
that are look down
upon the people that are born with a
silver spoon are also
minorities they look favorably you know
this because you don't even look
favorably on them and that's a majority
of people think the way you do they look
at people with Sil think that they
shouldn't have opinions no no see I pal
I think that your opinions are great and
I think that they're ideal and perfect
but I think that they're just not
reality that's
different wait wait wait wait wait wait
it used you know it used to be reality
yes it used to be reality you cannot
tell me it can't be reality and it's not
reality wait wait wait wait I'm going to
let you go I'm going to let you go one
side it used to wait it used to be
reality a 100 years ago 85% of people
were married and everybody stayed
married they got married and they stayed
married so it used to be a reality for
poor people and for rich people and I
think that's beautiful thing yeah and
you know this is why I think and I'm
going to I'm going to let her go cuz she
hasn't gone go ahead so I have a
traditional mindset where if I'm going
to have a child it has to be within
marriage um and go Queen the last result
is divorce because I care about my child
and their upbringing and I do believe
that two parents is better than one yes
100% you can get obviously there's um
exceptions there's abuse there's
physical abuse whatever you want to call
it but that's an exception then I would
choose to leave but it would be the last
resort and you've said exactly what
we've just sat there and said that's
exactly what we're saying but you know
what she she explained she explained the
difference between the exception and the
rule is what she did she didn't just say
she wasn't just um blurting random facts
it was understanding the difference
between the two she understand what we
were doing what cuz what you guys were
doing no I think what happened was you
was being more argument
because what we've said no no what what
we've said is very I feel like we all
kind of kind of been very clear everyone
actually agrees just in their own way no
I don't think we do though because again
you're looking at the exception instead
of the I always look at hold on one
second say what you said again in a
traditional mindset two is better than
one right so divorce would be my last
option right just so I don't break that
family Dynamic right and the child gets
that normal upbringing for the both
parents yes unless unless there's
exceptions where there's abuse which
were right okay so mental we said
exactly the same thing they say that
everyone's saying the same thing exactly
the same thing no but what I'm saying is
when you're giving when you're giving
out advice just have a
Bas she didn't have a base no no did you
he D she didn't she didn't say with the
adopted
orphan is that you don't go for a whole
Road okay okay okay we're done we're
done no no no no we're done we're done
we're done we're done okay we're going
to go to the next one the next thing
that men want okay I thought we would
pass that no no no I've been trying to
go back now men I want to hear from the
men first you could tell me if I'm wrong
or maybe I'm right who know maybe I know
nothing and I just don't look at facts
ever just terrible let's let's sh let's
show the next one not a complete [__]
yes so we're in 2023 so just so you guys
know 100 years ago most women were
virgins on their wedding days zero
Partners now the men are able to
compromise now on this and really these
days they just want not a complete
[__] they're like you know I mean
honestly three Partners was considered
the Town Bicycle back in the day now
that is a
godsend Zer five is the new so yeah 0o
to five is the new virgin which used to
be the Town Bicycle so men compromise I
know they were saying earlier men don't
compromise they do so now they say not a
complete [__] men true or false true
true true true women true or false true
true true wow this is amazing we go
through this oneck now the next one yeah
we really needed the other two for this
one oh that was they almost they almost
made it you know yeah they just not this
one yeah okay well you know all right
the next one does not argue yeah that's
men would just rather be with a chick
that is not
argumentative and doesn't argue then
they should be with a
man cuz every woman is opinionating no
they're not whoa that's not true let me
let me wa wait wait I'm giving you guys
a lot of air time I want to let the men
wom I I want to I'm going to let the men
and then I'm going to let I'm going to
let you go next go ahead yeah women um
that all women are opinion
that's not true I feel like a woman
that's deep into her feminity will
understand about being not argumentative
I would't say that there's anything
wrong with having a an opinion on
something but being argumentative and
having an argument with someone is very
different than having an opinion on
something what what a lot of women don't
understand yeah is we're not saying sit
there sh up and never ever talk right
I'm the captain you're the first mate
and if I respect you I'll take your
opinion on board but ultimately the
decision's mine but people don't want to
do that that's but that's how it should
be and I believe that's when women are
the happiest to be honest with you they
don't really want to think and plan
things a lot of the time you know so I
don't know maybe I'm wrong well the ones
laughing okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait I want to let the men go go ahead
go ahead no for me I feel like it's just
it's it's the tone like it's the voice
cuz at some point it's it gets to a
point where there's there's a disconnect
and it's just whose voice is louder so
that's kind of like where I lose
complete Focus you know so I I feel like
if you're if you're talking about you
know like whether the the fact that men
prefer like women that don't argue as
much it's probably because of that
single like thought in their minds that
if we get to an argument it becomes the
context of who's louder like whose voice
is louder so we're not even discussing
the topic anymore we're just trying to
like impose like okay my opinion is
above yours game what do you guys think
and then I'll let you
go yeah I mean I I agree I think um yeah
I mean why would would you want to be
with a woman who argues so much like you
just you know you want to come home to
like peaceful
environment you know someone who makes
you feel comfortable and you don't
constantly need to be like fighting with
them or um but at the same time I feel
like if you want a woman to be like that
you also need to be showing that you
have the qualities to be this masculine
guy that you're saying um and the is
that women face at the moment is we're
not seeing those qualities in the men so
we're going no I'm going to run [__]
basically that's I'm not saying it's
right I'm not sitting here saying it's
right but that is the reality and this
is why we have these problems right now
where women are just kind of like no I'm
not going to listen to the man cuz they
feel like the man is not capable of
leading actually don't agree we had a
conversation right the reality what what
I have noticed in the west is women
actually are shin away from masculine
men because women want to be in control
so most women are picking feminine men
whether they know it or not the Realties
most women want to be able to have their
saying relationship and when they're
with a man that doesn't let them have
their way they look at it as he's being
misogynistic he's being controlling he's
being this he's being that look at the
Pete
Davidson is well right yeah but I feel
like those but I feel like those those
are certain types of women and I I would
say that those type of women have things
like hyper independency and things like
that they come with all sorts of trauma
I feel like a woman who's just fully in
her feminine energy she would be happy
for the mant she what woman is fully in
her feminine energy in for example when
I'm with my partner I'll give an example
I'm very successful in my line of job
and when people see me talk you know you
see I'm people usually say I'm quite
dominant when I'm with my partner I want
to switch my brain off like I will do
what he says he will direct me he will
tell me where we're going today oh we're
getting on a plane he's got the
passports you know what I mean I don't
want to think
and I want to feel like he can just lead
and I know that a lot of women want that
feeling with men but they're not getting
that and I don't know what the problem
is I really don't well yeah what you I
agree with I agree with everything she
said because we would love to just
switch our brains no the reason why the
reason why and I would say this I'm not
even trying to poke into your
relationship but the reason why you are
in that situation is because your man I
mean I might I might just be
speedballing here but your man probably
has a lot of money I would say if if he
didn't have the money he did no matter
how masculine he is you wouldn't give
him that respect so you're talking about
oh I just want to switch off and give
him the passport the moment you said
passport I just knew the kind of man
you're speaking about and the reality is
women of old would be with an average
man and still respect him yeah I I agree
with that a lot of the time women don't
give actual safe space for them to be
masculine like how many women do we know
that would sub look at the start of the
show like we can't even just be direct
and just say it is how it is without
people say no you can't talk like that
and so it's not you're not creating and
even like even to lead like not
everyone's going to be the perfect
leader but if you don't make it a safe
space to make mistakes and then Rectify
those mistakes yeah yeah but the problem
is but the problem is money equals power
and that's probably why the women
respect the men better who have more
money the thing but the thing but the
thing is the thing is though the issue
is we have average women that won't
respect average men I'll give you an
example
the TV I don't know if you might have
been on that show the ebony Williams
ebony Williams she's she's in a similar
like line of work to us right TV
presenter 39 40 years old okay um
objectively that's a below average woman
by that age men aren't exactly lined up
to date 40-year-old women in in general
right and she's saying that she won't
respect her date a bus driver but really
you know the bus driver can still have a
normal family she can't and so what the
issue I would argue is that women that
are I would argue below average in
following are mad at men for being below
average in leading but it's like
everyone's below average who I mean even
I would argue even in two parent homes
homes most people didn't see traditional
relationships so everyone's just trying
to figure it out but it's like the women
have no Grace for the men I agree I
think for a relationship to where a man
has to feel masculine I mean he has to
full masculine you don't want to come
home I mean I voice my opinions okay but
when it comes to relationship I know how
to cook I know how to bake and I know
how to make a man feel respected um and
I think that there is sort of you know I
think that's General if you want a
relationship to work then you got to
have a man that feels more masculine
than a woman and I personally wouldn't
like to feel in a relationship like I'm
more Mas I do think there are roles as
well if everyone plays their role I'll
just saying you said you've said quite a
lot today that you don't want no man and
that's like very off putting forward guy
as well I didn't say I don't want no man
or like you're not
looking no it's not that it's not that
just independent lady not looking for a
man it's that focused if a right man
comes along and we got connection and we
get on then great but I'm not going to
lose my focus and focus on trying to
find a man so it's not I'm not looking
for a man I don't want of course I want
a man everyone wants a man to a man of
course but you know I'm I'm a man I'm
getting that Vibe I don't know if
everyone I'm just getting the
independent lady Don't Need No Man Vibe
that's all that's just all just that's
cool because you know it is what it is
I'm independent I could focus on my own
but the point is of call having Rel
relationship is nice and I know how to
resp respect a man treat a man cook for
a man bake for a man you know what I
mean I know how to treat a man but the
point is that if I don't have a man or I
haven't found anyone that I ain't got
that connection with I'm not going to
just sit around and be like oh my God
this poor I will focus on providing my
kids with a life that I don't have a man
that can provide that life to my kids
for and I will do that and then I
hopefully meet a man who can come and I
have an interesting question for you I
have an interesting question for you
your success yeah your success you've
gotten in your business business your
law firm and all of that did you get it
by being passive and be like well I
don't need this Law Firm I don't need
this absolutely not yeah there's a point
that's not how it is just by working
hard no but exactly so my point is you
get what you focus and work towards
absolutely by the fact that you've
already said and I'm not even trying to
go the fact you've already said that you
well you're not focused on having a man
if he comes he comes that that's not
what you're looking the focus is but
that's my point but that's literally the
reason you're probably not going to get
one it's terrible advice it's terrible
advice as well let's compare it so if if
I was focused on having a man and they
for I would have to be less focused on
my career I would be broke and single
not not necessarily though it will I'm
just saying yeah it's just it's bad
advice though because for me if you want
refering to advice who's given advice no
I'm saying like I'm just saying like in
general like it's brings that people I
just say that if you're focusing on you
want to attract a certain partner you
have to kind of be the way that person
that you're trying to um attract want
you to be so just a lot of women talk
about walk and say the right man will
come my life now it's probably not the
case you probably have to attract the
guy that you want to attract you just
that's what I'm saying you know what the
you you want know what the numbers are
actually it's actually it's going to be
a very sad for most women yeah yeah it's
going to be pretty bad yeah I mean
they're predicting and these are banks
right so banks are making invest these
are people that have no ball no skin in
this game all right they are just trying
to make money and they're predicting
half of women are going to be single and
childless 50% so half of the women are
we not going to have kids and the other
half that get married half a divorce
arguably higher than that um you know
they followed 40-year marriages found
67% divorce and a quarter of marriages
are sexless so I mean if we're going to
count successful marriages it's really
only 10% of us which so you know the
future is pretty Grim for everybody so
anyways
but it's but it's all right it doesn't
have to be Grim for you because I can
tell you exactly what guys want let's
pull to the next let's pull to the next
let's go to the next one so now again
usually we used to get this information
from our mothers and grandmothers but
unfortunately our mothers and
grandmothers have all led us astray
they've told us to always have a backup
plan and have never told us what men
want ever because most women are too
selfish to even care and are more
focused on other things now the next
thing that men want let's pull it up
drum roll
please all right all
right not old yes yes yes I had a
legendary tweet that got 15 million
views and I still couldn't believe it
all right I had a tweet that said
25-year-old women are hotter than
35-year-old women yes and I still have
women tweeting their selfies at me
proving to me how hot they are in their
old age now when you think about it the
average lifespan is about 77 years old
um let's let's just round it and say 80
35 you're almost halfway through your
life why do we keep saying that is Young
that is not young you're almost over the
hill you're almost done yes or over
halfway yes but we keep selling and I I
I would argue that the ultimate way to
sell anything is to convince women
they're young forever they do this with
Instagram filters Botox and plastic
surgery and a bunch of makeup to the
point that half the time chicks come on
my show if I follow them on Instagram
often times I don't recognize them it's
super crazy I'm like wow now um men like
young women does anybody disagree not
too young please please don't give me
any underage arguments that's not what
I'm saying of age but younger anybody
disagree
n the last few ones we've done I don't
know how to apprach I want to say no I'm
[Laughter]
joking
on I lost my 20 a 20 and I'd like to
actually go even further I had this
thought because all these women were
tweeting at me their selfies all right
and it was 35-year-old women and these
were the most beautiful 35-year-old
women I would say tip of the top and I
still thought to myself if I go to any
college campus I could find a chick
hotter yeah and it wouldn't be hard it
would be easy it' be like there's one
there's one there's one yes by 35 you're
on sale discount I guess I'm not getting
married then that's not what I said you
said over 25 no well I said 25's hotter
than 35 I would argue 20 is hotter than
25 typically in general men are going to
be more attracted to
I did you know statistically yeah most
of us it'll be a negative situ most of
us no happy ending sorry guys but but
there's hope because the next thing we
can learn let's go back to the power
point so we have a summary I a summary
to summarize men do not want fat
[Laughter]
[__] I I should have put don't want
old fat hores I my bad trying to stop RS
yeah yeah that absolute pandemonium in
it yeah no no no pandemonium I don't
think this is our like we should agree
right everyone agree no no no we agree
I'm just
saying can I can I add something goe I
just feel like we talked a lot about
like the word masculinity has been
thrown around a lot but we we didn't
even try to Define what masculinity is
for like most men cuz in that sense like
I feel like it might give a wrong
impression or a wrong idea that
masculinity is about overexerting your
dominance or like trying to you know
like stop problems I'm not saying that
that's the case but I'm just saying that
some people take it the wrong way so
maybe we could try to like you know now
all people that are emotional and like
that they're not masculine when you're
masculine you can control your emotions
so all these people out here chinging
and doing all this stuff they're not
masculine men they're over emotional
example I write music I write music and
that's like an emotional experience for
me so does that take away that's not the
same you're talking about overexerting
yourself and being violent like Mas I
would say most musicians are a little
more feminine yeah I'm getting slight
feminine I'm not going to lie I'll be
honest with you bro like I'm getting
slight I I'm not saying you but I'm
saying like I mean maybe maybe a little
bit but get like but I'm a tomboy so
it's like no no who's who's no one's
perfect right but I'm saying like um
like I don't know typically when I look
at the guys in music today I I YouTube
too to be honest I think YouTube kind of
like a lot of guys are more feminine
yeah like Harry sty Harry Harry sty
to defend him a little bit I actually I
actually don't think like music and all
of that makes any on feminine I actually
think masculinity is more about taking
responsibility being someone of your
word being like having a like like
having a baseline value that you don't
stray from and no one no matter what
anyone says about you no what no matter
how how people try to push you off your
Square you stand your ground that's what
masculinity is you say You Preach Sir
You Preach can can I just try to like
explain myself on this one cuz like for
example I'm North African I'm from Libya
so I had a very different upbringing
probably to most people over here you
know and growing up for example or
experiencing a Civil War and whatnot I
like it's it's just like you know what I
mean like it you've seen certain things
or you've seen men go like and transform
in a way or do things that they can't
you know go back from so it's like at
some point the idea of masculinity even
even within those spaces has just become
that like of violence it's just become
that yeah yeah you know it's just become
like it's my way or nothing because it's
so accessible to just say like you know
how you say cancel culture I'll cancel
you but there it's like you're dead like
it's like you know what I mean it's that
to that point to that extreme in certain
places so when I when I bring in that
perspective I'm looking at that and
relating it to my background from what I
know yeah but obviously masculinity
there is an aspect of of you know
violence with that but I'm just saying
to be masculine an experience where I've
almost personally died and that was the
last time I've ever went back to Libya
which was like in 2014 yeah yeah well
I'm saying like for me I'm just saying
masculine would be someone who can
control their emotions yeah that's
masculine well I think I think I guess
my point with the musician thing was
more in music they're just pushing
feminine dudes nowadays you know you
know what I mean like it's I mean the
way I see for example for Me music and
I'm not trying used to be like rock
stars you know what I mean like that was
kind of more of a masculine but now it's
like it's like guys that kind of are
singing like women a
lot popular now dbe they sound like
women de block Europe is really popular
with like women har sty I'm thinking of
Harry Styles that's why I just keep I
keep getting him in my
head no I'm not I'm not they're both
very similar both artists both well both
groups of artists I don't know who that
is but yeah that's what I mean that's
what I'm trying to throw out there that
you're not too far off anyway they're
both really similar or even like One
Direction you rap but you don't know who
DB
is and you're a rapper well I mean I do
dabble I don't know nobody's asked me to
be on a track yet I'm like waiting you
can't you two collaborate I don't know
why I've had Auntie Jenny some point
tell me that she wanted to hear us play
oh no way you should do the freestyle
you should play and she should freestyle
watching your freestyles oh yeah I got
in I got in trouble for the
freestyle um we all agree for once what
we all agree for once yeah we've done
really well for the last few can I say
something about masculinity yeah I think
that you know the argu argumentative
women that only happens if a man doesn't
bring peace so if a man knows his role
the women will automatically submit oh
no oh no oh that's
thing from the truth no no no no I I
think that's an excuse argumentative
women use to be honest is because you're
disagreeing well yeah but it's have a
discussion I need a man you can control
me no no no just stop being
argumentative please but didn't you say
you have to respect the women I just
feel like arguing is like a cry for help
sometimes with women because they've
they've probably overlooked some signs
that the guy wasn't right for them and
then when they're arguing it's what do
you guys expect marriage to be like you
could have the most masculine man ever
you don't think you're going to argue
but you should have I mean Tom Brady got
divorced what was his wife whining
about you know what I mean you're
telling me Tom Brady's not
masculine
really I think I think I think he I
think he was an author and then they was
beating each other senseless yeah that's
what it
was um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
and then we're going to close out the
show okay all right 90 freetail pie
um says the homely is XX men are oh [__]
okay the homely women are lying are
lying when they stay it when they when
standing um they are the same things to
prove it ask them whatever question but
before they answer they have to repeat
the
question um Dragon stallion 10001 at
some point in marriage you're going to
love and dislike the person at the time
but because the woman is unhappy she'll
leave and file for divorce instead of
working it out uh 93 topai um Pearl I've
advised many of times that after a woman
asks a question to stay quiet and watch
them explode also abortion is is evil 93
to P thanks to Planned Parenthood more
basketball Americans have deleted so
much that their numbers would be two
times if Planned Parenthood it didn't
exist um the puffy Vagas um to the
lawyer women are a more Unfaithful than
the men Chris um to fake lawyer thanks
for pushing back at Pearl I'm a rich men
who relies on women like you to co-sign
the [__] I tell my side chicks so
that I can pump and dump them on birth
control thanks again holiday tone
delusional women over 9,000 on this
pamel um puffy um puffy Vegas this
lawyer is insane she's 34 and has two
kids and I am a high value man none of
us would take her seriously the lawyer
is delusional she'll die alone wait wait
I'm going to let you respond but I need
to get through them uh puffy Vegas all
the friends and girlfriends wives
offered wait wait puffy Vegas all my
friends and girlfriends wives offered
sex uh puffy Vegas can we stop the lies
all oh can we stop the lies all women
she all of my girlfriends um and wives
have have been offered sex from the
fronts okay Chris notice how immature
the two blondes in the middle are they
sulk in their seats and say I'm just not
going to talk after they get corrected
narcissists Chris men do a better job of
giving advice because men see themselves
in men while women see other women as
competition December 08 ladies you can
convince the entire world being a [__]
isn't bad but evil is still evil
telephone 9265 sleeping with multip PE
multiple people is not accidental I'm
shocked holiday
tone holiday tone I'm shallow she's cap
you're not living in real life Chris um
says ladies I if I say um most people
have 10 fingers are you going to say
that I can't have that because some
people have nine figures fingers stop
arguing just to argue Let me refresh it
really quick and see if there's any more
Super chats before we close out this
show think of any final thoughts that
you guys have in the time and then I
will let you guys respond in a second
Dakota um still slart Pearl if you ever
come to the West Coast of Canada I want
to take to you to dinner 63 Jack of all
es in a business owner wow what a
day sounds like the ultimate guy 90
freet to pie a beautiful 35-year-old
will never beat an ugly 19-year-old
Patrice O'Neal also red shirt is a beta
being a man is doing what's right no
matter what sorry
guys sorry 90 okay that's all of them
anyways um I think that's it I'm going
to refresh it real quick no one said
anything about all speak I know we made
it left out we made
it culture one more time well yeah you
know anyways why don't we do final
thoughts um we'll start here go around
and then we'll do second row you feel
free to plug any social media or only
fans but they
left go ahead um my final thoughts are
that my men and women both have
responsibility when it comes to Children
marriage um divorcing is but um I think
the traditional way works so we should
bring that back
um oh you can't hear
me so the traditional way works for a
reason so we should try and bring that
back but I'm a Muslim so I do think um
traditionally um so that's where my
point of views come from and stem from
but um ultimately it stand to respect if
you respect your partner you'll treat
them well and you'll have a healthier
relationship overall that's my two pens
so um well firstly Pa thank you for
having me on the show again um yeah know
it was really interesting to hear
everyone's point of view and I
definitely understand that life is just
not black and white um but yeah I um
again same as you very traditional and
just I just think it's all about respect
and
you know we all need to know our our
roles to to live in a healthy
partnership or marriage so yeah and
you're coming on the therapy episodes I
am can you tell like I'm like preparing
myself for it I know it's going to be
it's going to be a fun I've been like
thinking a lot tonight like you know
yeah yeah probably probably end of
October we'll film it so it'll be fun F
okay yeah and um if you want to keep
keep up to date with me I'm on all
socials uh Instagram ska TV
Tik tok's Kaa Louisa and um yeah just
catch me on another
podcast uh yeah um what was I supposed
to say oh we do we do any final thoughts
you have on the show anything anything
you want to say and then socials if you
have them yeah I mean it's it's just
like I said is like we talked a lot
about I feel like the realities that
exist within the Western world and then
obviously we don't want to go back and
forth and saying there's exceptions this
there's exceptions that but there's
social there's certain like
social/cultural
structures that provide much more
guidance for men and women cuz I'm a
Muslim as well so like depending on like
how the families get involved Etc like
guiding them for example it's not that
they women don't date they do but it's
very controlled is supervised there's a
proper manner of how things get done
because I got three sisters as well so
for example I look out for my sisters
too and I make sure that everything is
kind of like you know like I'm involved
within their lives so I feel like yeah
so it's just a matter of like
understanding that the parents as well
need to be very involved within their
children's lives and kind of like
supervise and manage that you know help
them sorry know manage that and then if
there's one last thing that I'd like to
say because I feel like people back home
would just be angry at me if I didn't
which is like you know if um it's kind
of like this thing happen in DNA where
like the Daniel storm hit and if anybody
wants to support you know Libya in any
way there's multiple organizations in
the UK there's like the Islamic relief
and that's probably one of the most
trusted ones you can donate there if you
want to support people in North Africa
and Libya that were like affected by the
storm thank
you prolific official thank you for
having me I've really enjoyed my time
and it's been interesting listening to
everybody's opinions I've actually
learned a lot today
um you know power point was helpful was
being it was great it was great it and
it was nice to listen to the younger
Generations as well do you know what I
mean um but ultimately I would say that
as much as we can go by statistics so on
and so forth like this gentleman said
you know there's a lot to life and
everything isn't black and white it
depends on you know your cultural
background it depends on you know what
part of the world that you come from
everyone's got different experiences do
you know what I mean life is definitely
not black and white um yeah so I'm
prolific official p r o l i f i official
on all social
platforms hi um some just going to say
that out of all the conversations I
probably agreed with everything PE said
now I'm joking um but no I'm joking um
heart
attack no for real um I mean look I mean
it was nice but on the show so thanks
for inviting me um I've never done
anything like this before um I'm quite a
passionate female but I'm also
passionate about um what goes on in the
streets outside and you guys will know
about the knife crime and a little um 16
15 year old girl and the 16 year old boy
followed by the 22y old you know what's
happening with that um and there is so
much more to me other than debates but
about you know knife crime on the
streets but also about representing
those that arrested when they're
actually innocent for things so you know
I I'm here um I work for SVS listeners
I've got a shout out to my colleagues
otherwise they won't forgive me that's
janed khah and James so we sort of win
cases together um but yeah no it's nice
to be on the
show yeah well thanks for letting me hop
on again uh I always like coming on
because it's I I believe you can't learn
about the world unless you you speak to
people when you speak to people you
disagree with it's only through
disagreements that we can broaden our
knowledge of the space that we live in
and and and strive for better um you
know couple of things look perspectives
matter of course and it's important that
we acknowledge exceptions in life
however it doesn't matter if Newton said
it if Einstein said it or if I said it
gravity is gravity what goes up must
come down and I think it's important
that in society we can acknowledge broad
statements about the world and decide
what the best way forward is broadly we
don't always have to go into the
exception so if you're interested in
Broad statements and learning about
patterns in society and what we can do
about it come and check out my YouTube
channel I have a series called debunk in
the lunacy where we debunk some of the
mess going on in society right now and
we try and figure out a way to move
forward broadly yes but for hopefully
the best so if that sounds like
something you'd be into check me out my
name is Christine Grace Smith you can
find me on Instagram stagram or on
YouTube she getting good at the yes can
I forget I forgot to mention my um I
forgot to mention my Instagram by the
way it is lawyer Dolly if anybody wants
to
follow took my time there lawyer Dolly
not very happy about that um it's great
be back on the show just. BK socials um
part of the council culture team my
opinions uh my thoughts today I mean
look we need to stop delusion I think
that's it mainly for me let's start
lying to each other ladies I feel like
if you're more honest with your fellow
girl you will feel a lot more happier I
don't know what could be more better
like me me you me being a girl and me
and my girl going off on holiday and I
feel good and she looks good and we're
both looking good instead of me just
looking good and she looks big and I'm
just like no girl you look good no no
that's not good I feel like more
honestly be be straight and that means
in anything you know if you want a man
with money you want a man that's rich
you want a man that can look after you
be real about it don't don't hide about
it be straight about it I feel like
you're looking at me but I am I am
you've been the most argumentative so I
am looking at you but I know you haven't
said that my job is to argue what's
right I I'm argumentative but you know
there all the points of I'm straight
down the middle Mutual I'm I'm not
purposely looking I'm just saying like
in general now but in in all fairness
I've had a great time love love coming
on the Pod and you know love hearing
everyone's perspective as an idea make
sure you tune in to councel culture
podcast 0121 Birmingham podcast best
podcast in Birmingham so make sure you
tune in and check it out yeah I mean I
agree with daral gentleman to my left um
I think we need to stop the delusion
life is black and white and um yeah if
you're interested in hearing less
delusion and arguing that life is black
and white obviously check out the coun
coach podcast you like what I did there
yeah you did do we can do so it's the
coun coach podcast on Instagram on
YouTube go subscribe to that go follow
that and um yeah and final thoughts on
the show uh it's just the usual a lot of
delusion by the end of the show people
kind of come to terms and gets a lot
easier so yeah and and it's like it's
like you guys you're going to be on the
oh yeah like I get I get
these we're going to be on the audacity
Network as well we went out today um
asking people about abortion actually
ironically um and yeah it
was um we'll see you'll see
the so guys we're we're compiling a
bunch of footage from um people that
have been on the show um so it's going
to be interesting you'll have you'll see
like fan favorites I know I know you
guys have a LoveHate relationship with
denva okay I know you do I know you do
but we love her we love her here so um
you know she's going to do some stuff um
I think carnivore Fitness is going to do
some stuff for us um basically some of
the familiar faces China you know that
you've seen in the past year we're going
to put on the network page and it's just
going to be really cool and fun um so if
you want to be involved in any of those
projects you can message me on Instagram
just pearly things one um it's not
always going to be the super serious
stuff some of it's going to be like fun
oh King has a boxing match this weekend
so if you guys want to see King box I'm
going to be there and a bunch of other
people are going to be there from the
show and the staff here so if you want
to meet us go to his boxing match if you
want to take it all you have to do is DM
King on Instagram the link to his
Instagram is in the description um also
uh make sure you like the video and if
you want to be on the audacity n network
make sure you message me on Instagram
and there's one more Super Chat which is
from 90 fro pie Pearl read reads Super
Chat so bad that you treat them like a
fetus oh [__] wow wow thank you for that
all right great way to end the show all
right like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next
time